大家好 在节目开始之前我插播一条语音。
因为这个节目是在5月14号晚上录制完成的。
那么5月15号的下午 理想L9这款车型就正式上市了。
三点钟直播一直到四点十分 现在是四点十二分。
四点十分的时候就已经把所有的正式官方售价。
以及它的销售权益公开了。
那么原先我们得到的消息不是特别的准确。
我们一开始得到的消息是指上理想L9Leave。
就只公开这个车的价格。
那么理想L9的常规的版本要等到后期在进行上市一两个月之后。
但是没想到这次是两个配置都上了。
理想L9Leave包括全新理想L9的Altra。
所以你可以理解为理想L9的顶配以及理想L9的特别版。
或者说是定制版 这两个版本的价格都公开了。
那么L9的Leave的售价是509800。
这个509800跟它之前的也就是预售的价格。
559800 相当于是下伏了5万块钱。
这个也是不少人没想到的。
网上猜测的基本上都是在下伏2万到3万。
52 53的样子。
没想到这次是一下子下伏了5万块钱。
那么L9Altra的版本它的定价是459800。
那么这个价格如果是相比于老版本。
就是上一代的Altra。
439800上伏了2万块钱。
但是这两个价格都不是最终的到手的价格。
为什么呢？
因为它后来出了一个权益政策。
第一 你只要是在6月30号之前下定的话。
是可以直接围款抵2万块钱。
那么言外之意就是说。
在刚刚这个价格基础上还要再减2万。
那么这么一减下来的话。
一个就是489800。
那么另外一个就是439800。
那么439800。
相当于就跟之前老款的Altra版本的价格是一模一样的。
一分钱不差
那么除此之外
它还有一个老车主的回购复购的权益。
那么就再减1万块钱。
之前的一些销售政策其实也是都有的。
那么在除此之外
它这次还送了很多东西。
那么L9的Altra相当于是送了。
官方的说法是价值6万块钱的。
第一个就是电容房甲智能电关门。
就是四个车门全都是电动的。
而且是带房甲的
那么这四个门的话。
你要单独选是1万5000块钱。
现在是送的
还有就是它的9.3.6。
无瑕新环剧院音响。
5440瓦的分支功率33个扬声器。
那么这一套也是送的。
那么官方说法是价值3万块钱。
还有一个就是前排的双零中立座椅。
这个说是价值1万5000块钱。
那么这三样东西现在目前都是送的。
那么加在一起价值6万。
如果这些东西都算在一起的话。
你可以理解为其实L9。
就是正常的版本
Altra的版本就是降价了。
那么其实现在就是唯一的悬炼。
L9是不是就只有Altra。
跟Livis这两个版本。
那么以前的pro版本难道就没有了吗？
我个人估猜
它应该是看一看市场的销售情况。
如果说那都不购卖。
或者说销量要超预期。
那么短时间内
它应该是不会再出地版本的pro配置。
为什么呢？
因为这个车毕竟是立标杆。
理想目前最旗舰的车型。
除了这个以外
你找不到比它更贵的了。
当然了
它纯电这个车型
将来肯定也是要往上打。
现在I8
I6
那实际上只有I6卖的好。
对吧？
I8销售也没有太完全达到它的预期。
那么将来你要再出什么I9。
或者是什么I9L。
Altra
或者是叫I9Livis。
那你必须得要先
在它最擅长的增成的这个版本里面。
要把价格立得住
所以这个车子它是有战略意义的。
如果L9的Livis的销量。
和它的这种品牌标识。
客户兴致
它没有站得住
那将来对于它的纯电产品。
是有非常大的影响。
所以L9的高端
要如果能站得住的话。
纯电今后就会日子好过一点。
所以在节目一开始。
我就赶紧插播一条这样的信息。
把这个最新的资讯。
融到我们的节目里面。
那么大家如果有什么想说的。
也可以评论去交流。
好
那么接下来是我们今天正式的节目。
欢迎各位说
今天这期摆设全说。
我是三刀
前两天去北京
去试驾理想L9Livis。
那么有些朋友
已经在我的微博上看到了。
我说
具体的一些消息
不太方便提前透露。
为什么呢？
因为这个提前透露的话。
它的保密协议
是罚款1000万。
没有听错
1000万
我当时看到这个数字。
我都惊了
我说其他的品牌
保密协议是500万。
我说为什么你们家是1000万。
然后那工作人员说。
我也不是很清楚
因为上面的领导说。
就是1000万
所以很明显
这理想对于这款车子的一些。
相关信息
它的这个保密工作。
做的还是
或者说看的还是比较重的。
而且非常巧合的一个事情。
是什么？
这个我们讲一个小八卦。
就是在当天
我入住活动现场的酒店的时候。
我接到了一条消息。
也是通过盾牌
有人联系到我们
说要跟我做一个
线上的电话采访
这个是付费用的
然后问了一下
这个费用还不低
然后他就发了一个。
叫做仿钱的
叫做钱采
说能不能先文字
把相关的问题点
先给我们沟通一下。
这个也很正常
我也会
也不能说是精彩
就每一年我会遇到好几次。
这种咨询公司做一些进调。
一些采访
因为我试过很多车。
他们可能会给一些品牌。
去做相关的咨询
然后拿到信息之后。
给他们做一些咨询方案。
那么采访我们这些。
就是汽车圈的媒体。
我想这个
帮他做咨询
也没啥问题
可能他问的都是一些。
行动员方面的一些问题。
因为他跟我说了
大方向是行动员车。
我是没问题
可以回答
但是我看到他给我的问题之后。
在5月13号这个时间点。
然后他问的问题
全都是关于理想L9的Leoys。
而且他的每一个问题。
都是具体到
车辆的相关信息
我当时第一反应就是。
我的妈
我才签了一个
1000万的保密协议。
然后他现在就要
跟我做电话采访
你这不就等于是无形之中。
想让我去提前
去透露商业信息吗？
所以你看
现在行动员车
互相之间的竞争多么的激烈。
那我肯定是拒绝
对吧？
我不可能说
为了一个咨询的费用。
然后冒这么大风险。
我就给他提出了我的质疑。
然后对方的意思就是说。
可以匿名
然后对方也可以
跟我签保密协议
就是说他们不会
把我的信息透露出去。
我说不可以
即使是这样
我也不可能接受采访。
我说或者是这样子。
就是你5月15号之后。
理想L9Leoys。
他上市之后
相关信息公布了
如果你对于这款车。
还有一些后期市场上的一些判断。
这方面你可以来问我。
因为这车我也试过了。
对吧？
它有哪些优点
有哪些缺点
有哪些消费者的痛点。
已经解决了
有哪些是没有解决的。
它跟老款车行之间的一些差别。
包括对于它的销量。
那些推测
这些我都可以去回复。
但是你在这个时间点。
还没上市之前
你想拿到这些信息。
那我觉得
这个是
我觉得至少从职业操守上来讲。
是肯定是不合适的。
所以把它拒绝掉了。
然后对方说
那行吧？
那就跟客户沟通一下。
看看5月15号之后。
要不要再做一个采访。
那么到今天是5月14号。
还没有接到任何的消息。
所以你看
说实话
干我们这个行业风险也挺大的。
有的时候它不停的会有一些诱惑。
对吧？
那个资金的费用真的是不低。
而且就一个小时的时间。
接受电话采访
一个小时
那可能是很多人一个月的工资。
甚至很多人一个月。
他都不一定能挣那么多的钱。
好
我们就讲个题外话。
我们今天具体就聊一聊。
理想L9 Lewis这款车。
那么在讲之前
我先讲一讲
我也是这两天发生的事情。
我就发现在微博上。
淡繁去聊理想的车型。
或者说淡繁去发任何。
跟理想相关的消息。
网友第一反应就是。
你是不是商业
你有没有站队
你是不是站在理想这一侧。
你是不是在帮理想说话。
你是不是在夸他
那么同时在发任何。
跟理想相关信息的时候。
你有没有去对比
比如说有没有对比未来。
有没有对比问界
有没有对比小鹏
或者说对比小鹏一般比较少。
或者是对比小米
就这一类的车型
大家都知道
现在的这种互联网的氛围。
我是觉得不太好
然后有很多的QC。
那么这些QC
他们会主导
就是说
我就占这个品牌
我就帮这个品牌去发声。
那么同时
他们肯定也是吃这个品牌的饭。
对吧？
参加这个品牌的活动。
帮这个品牌去做宣传。
他们也是车主
因为我说的QC
一般都是车主的意见领袖。
对吧？
所以当反你发这些信息。
有的时候
他会怎么传播到
这些人的消息
会传到他们手上
一般都是什么？
一般比方说有一些。
这些人都是普通的网友。
他看到了之后
三当讲了比方说理想。
再聊理想
中间提到了未来
他们可能会把这条微博。
或者是把这个视频。
直接转到他们群里面。
那么这个群有可能是QC那的群。
也有可能只是一个大群。
然后是车友会
或者怎么滴
那么有QC在这里面。
发过去之后
QC看到了之后
QC就可能会提出。
一些他们自己的想法。
一般都是这种比较对立的。
或者是比较质疑的想法。
那么这样的话
有一波人会从群里面。
直接跳转到微博
然后在评论区里面。
会发一些这种
带有一定攻击性的。
这样的一个评论
为什么我这么讲
其实我就发现
我试完之后
因为很多信息不能讲。
但是我对于
这台车最大的一个印象点。
在哪
就是它的800伏伏的主动旋挂。
其实之前在
未来的车上我们也试过。
那么最近的这一批。
就是全新的问界的M9。
这个车型
那么我们也有同事去试这个车。
那么其实大家都知道。
就是如果是在主动旋挂。
如果你试过主动旋挂。
比方说ET9或者是ES9的话。
那么基本上
试过的人
不管是专业的媒体。
还是普通的用户
试过之后会发现
这台车子的整个的。
底盘质感是跟我们。
之前开过的那些
非主动旋挂的时候。
完全不一样
你说震撼
我觉得也是可以用这个词的。
从我角度来讲
我想用的词是如履平地。
当然了
未来的这一套操作模式。
跟我们今天试的800伏主动。
还是有点不太一样。
它那个是48伏的。
讲的一个主动旋挂。
天行地盘
我当时发微波的时候。
因为我是在敦坑
我在敦坑
大家就敦坑
有点味道
敦坑
那么敦坑的时候
我就在想说
我来发一发我的感受。
这个也不涉及到什么保密协议。
那么我大概的意思。
其中有一句话
我是这么讲的
这句话确实不严谨。
我当时说了
我说目前市面上
在L9李维斯之前。
就是大家能看到的800伏主动旋挂。
比方说像问界的M9 Ultimate。
对吧？
他们家那个
特别版或者说是叫M9家常版。
那么这款车型
其实它的价格要到7，820万。
然后我说
包括未来的ES9。
我说像这些车
都是要7，820万。
你看理想的L9的李维斯。
他现在把价格拉低到了50多万。
那么后面的这一段话的意思。
其实我是想讲这个技术。
大家即使你现在的预算买不起。
也一定要去体验一下。
因为应该按照我的判断。
很快一两年之内
这个技术100%是要下方下来的。
那么后面就下方到可能是。
30多万的车
那么再往后是20多万的车。
那么不管是中大型的SUV。
中型的SUV仅侧型的。
再往后包括轿车
对吧？
中大型的轿车
中型的仅侧型的轿车。
像这种800%负责主动旋挂。
它要是普及的话
绝对是对于底盘的。
或者说我们的价称的。
体感上的一个质的提升。
结果就这一段话
那么很多人就有质疑了。
那么质疑几个点
第一个
你凭什么说M9和ES9。
要卖到7、80万。
有那么贵吗？
这一点确实我是不严谨的。
应该正常来讲的话。
他们应该是60上下。
落地的话应该是60多万。
我当时印象里面6、70。
尤其是我写的时候。
就稍微跨大了一点。
我写了个7、80。
所以说被大家喷也很正常。
这个我认
那么第二个
因为我把温静M9 Ultimate。
包括未来的ES9。
我把它统一放在了800副主动旋挂里面。
这个也是不严谨的。
因为未来确实
它不是800副的主动旋挂。
它走的技术路线
和800副主动确实不一样。
它是一个48副的主动旋挂。
但是我当时老子里面想的就是。
他们就是在L9 Levis。
之前上市的主动旋挂的车。
因为这两台车子
重点宣传的也是这个。
所以这两点
我为网友喷的
今天有点小郁闷
但是我觉得很正常。
那么让我也是补足了一个。
也算是知识盲区
我不是很严谨
也没有非常细致的去。
把这里面的技术
包括它的原理
了解得很清楚
然后我就发了这条微博。
我觉得我被喷的
很正常
活该
我活该
所以我今天也是恶补了一下。
那么恶补完之后
我就发现这里面
很多东西非常有意思。
就包括主动旋挂
这个东西到底是
有什么样的一些
不同的技术路线
包括它对我们的这样的。
一个体验
为什么我当时在去。
试ES9，1T9的时候。
它的这个感受
和我这次去试
L9 Levis的感受。
会有比较大的差别。
这一点我就算是搞明白了。
那么甚至于包括
这个理想的
48F的这样的
一个主动旋挂的供应商。
或者是要深度的合作伙伴。
也就是国外的Clear Motion。
他们的工程师的访谈。
他参加了一个
视频的播客节目
那么这个节目
我也找到了
然后我觉得非常好。
我也是发到了微博上。
结果大家对这个毫无兴趣。
反正我看评论
包括播放量都不是很高。
所以网友呢？
我觉得很有意思
就是说你说错了
我就肯定要喷你
但是你要如果真的想。
跟我普及一些知识。
跟我讲一些什么理论的东西。
那我是不是很感兴趣的。
所以我觉得音频这一块。
是我的一个
真的
我觉得像我一个小树动一样。
或者说是我的一个。
回到家里面的一个小港湾。
跟大家一起烙一烙心里话。
在外面受到一些什么委屈了。
我就回到我的家里面。
跟大家来聊聊天
我也是普通的一个汽车媒体人。
我也不是三头六臂。
什么都懂对吧？
我也不是百科全书。
我是百科全书
但我不是百科全书。
对吧？
所以共同学习
今天是让我好好地学习了一下。
行
我们就展开来慢慢地聊吧？
先聊一聊理想的L9的Levis。
这个产品呢？
其实一开始
我也是没有时间具体研究。
我当时一直以为
就是全新的L9换代了。
然后他可能
这一系列的车型都叫L9Levis。
因为我以为是理想。
后期会把他们家的产品。
全部都把后面加一个。
这种标叫Levis。
然后后来我才发现。
不是这么回事
他这个Levis。
其实就有点像
比如说这个未来的签名版。
或者是什么？
低频线定制版
或者像是U M9的Ultimate。
它是一个类似
于旗舰车型的一个名称。
或者说是
它的一个特别版
定制版的一个名称。
那么这一次5月15号。
反正我得到的消息。
就是它是先上L9Levis。
它最旗舰的一个版本先上。
然后再过一两个月的时间。
再去发布全新一代的L9。
所以说你如果想买的。
不是Levis
你只是想买一个
普通版本的L9的话。
可能15号那一天。
你只能了解到的
都是他们家最旗舰的一些。
相关的功能 配置。
但是价格就要到50来万了。
因为它的预售价是。
那么你肯定会认为说。
L9这个车
不就是应该是
40多万的车吗？
你怎么卖到50多万了。
人家都是在降价
你的价格怎么越卖越贵了。
所以你要搞清楚
它多的这10来万。
相当于它会有专属的一些配置。
不管是它的标
会带Levis的英文的尾标。
包括它的整个的车辆的外观。
包括它的轮圈
它的造型
包括我刚刚讲到
这些硬件的配置
包括四激光雷达
很多的东西都是它专属的。
那么会不会下放到。
L9的普通版本上。
目前我们不是很清楚。
但是你想想看
价格差10万
它即使下放
最起码也得是M9的顶配。
它不可能是入门版本。
那么入门版本
如果你要想要这些功能。
那可能有一些就需要再选装。
那么选来选去
肯定也都是接近50万。
所以说Levis这个版本。
不仅仅是从外观上。
你能够一眼就能判断出。
它是一个最顶配的版本。
那么从功能上
硬件上来讲的话
它确实也是按照
就是说满配中的满配区。
非常顶的
去给它做这种设定的。
所以它的价格就贵了。
10来万块钱
我们讲一讲L9的历史。
L9这个车子
其实是在2022年。
6月份刚推出的
那么2022年
到现在一转眼
已经是4年过去了。
我们知道
其实新能源这个市场上。
你别说4年了
你现在过个半年
有些技术
就可能已经略险落后了。
就是它的更新速度非常快。
我们之前聊即可001。
对吧？
一年换三代
那个是特殊情况
正常情况下
它其实一年换一代也差不多了。
只不过当时
正好是遇到小米苏711上市。
中间想提前结个壶。
结果那个结壶没结成功。
然后等小米上市了。
它又做了一个更新的版本。
就是一下子就中间为隔半年。
就更新了一次
所以网友调侃是一年更三代。
对吧？
那么之前也更新了一次。
中间更新
后来又更新
那么这个是特殊情况。
大多数的产品
基本上是一年一小改。
但是在智能驾驶
包括智能坐舱
新能源这一种车型。
它的这个改
其实改动还是比较大的。
我这个例子比较说芯片。
如果说出了新的芯片。
它有的时候
不会是说它不想改。
而是它的这些芯片的供应商。
它的更新速度非常快。
我们知道手机的芯片。
更新就非常快
对吧？
苹果手机是一年上一个新款。
你像我上个期节目。
我说我要买手表
我这边还真正为买着呢？
马上9月份
什么S12的手表要上了。
我合计者现在都5月份了。
我也不是急着用
那么在等三四个月。
我不就能买到最新款了吗？
你包括像什么MacBook。
MacBook Neo那个笔记本。
很多人说那个笔记本。
完全不是属于
苹果正常的笔记本。
但是我觉得对我来讲。
写稿子什么是够用的。
可是你今年不买
再等个一年
明年就是16G了。
今年是8G
对不对
明年可能芯片也会再提升。
能耗再变得更低一点。
续航变得再长一点。
你就看你急不急
急你现在就买
不急就不买
不过我现在基本上放弃了。
为什么我放弃了
因为这两天
我正好就参加了一个讨论。
也是有一些玩龙虾的讨论。
因为前两天理想
不是跟罗勇号
有一期关于人工智能的一个探讨吗？
我不知道大家看的没有。
内容相对来讲是比较枯燥的。
但是那一期的播客我听完了。
我也是强烈建议
如果大家对于AR。
人工智能
对于什么小龙虾智能体。
你要如果感兴趣
你可以去听一听
虽然说理想本人
他没有这28年的读过大学。
但是你听完之后
你会发现
这哥们真的
我虽然不想说
过多的去夸他
怎么怎么怎么好
因为我知道很多人不喜欢理想。
这个人的性格
但是你去听完之后。
你就知道
这绝对不是一个
大学没上过的人
然后他能在领域里面。
说出来的一些话
人家是实战派
是二八经实战
他讲到几个点很有意思。
他说什么？
他们公司里面的这个。
这个token是无限量供应。
无限量供应
然后他每个月
回去看一看
他们整个公司里面。
就是用token。
用的最多的这20个人。
然后跟他们随机抽那么一两个人。
到他办公室
去进行一对一的一个沟通。
这个很有意思
他当时给了一个观点是什么？
他说
如果这个公司的员工。
在没有使用小龙虾。
没有使用这套智能体制钱。
你觉得他的这个工作效率也好。
或者工作能力也好。
不是特别好
你不要急着
在上智能体之前
把这些人给开掉
你先别急着去否定他。
有的时候往往这个智能体一上。
你反而不是那些
原先就是技术很好的人。
他能够保持他的效率。
就反而中间层的这一波人。
就是人家不说了吗？
之前有一个新闻是讲。
就是搞技术的
反而他学文科的人。
通过智能体
他做的反而比别些。
那些之前搞技术的人更好。
为什么呀？
因为他会表达
因为他会系统性的去思考问题。
他能够把他讲的那些问题点。
用文字去跟智能体去沟通。
他的沟通能力更强。
所以他能够很快的得到一些效果。
那么另外一点
当时罗永浩讲了一个问题点是什么？
说你怎么看将来有了。
这些龙虾智能体之后。
那么一人公司
就一个人就能开个公司。
或者说是两三个人。
小规模的四五个人。
就能去制造一个大公司。
才能去完成的这些工作。
那么当时理想讲了一个观念。
我觉得挺有意思
没有工作环境
就是我大概理解的意思是这样的。
我不知道理解对不对。
有些人也听过他们的博客。
你可以去在评论区沟通。
他的意思我理解
就是说你首先要有一个大致的。
工作的目标和工作的方向。
而绝大多数的人去玩智能体。
其实最多就是想
我能不能就我少干点活。
对吧？
我用龙虾去帮我干活。
或者说是我就玩一玩。
我来看一看
比如说我在网上去发一些。
我的自媒体的内容。
他可以帮我去寻找一些最新的资讯。
帮我整理一些什么相关的。
这些信息
帮我去发发帖子
写些稿子
这些东西
他的意思就是你一定要在一个。
已有的工作环境里面让他去跑。
那么这样的话
你就会有非常清晰的目标。
并且让他的目标
达成的过程当中
可以去验证他的效率。
是不是比你手搓
比你自己的不借助AI。
效率要高得多的多的多。
如果说你发现智能体。
一旦要是用顺了
那你可能就离不开了。
对吧？
他有一个高管
当时是不愿意用
他说那个人本身技术就比较好。
他觉得这东西没有必要。
我自己技术那么好。
干嘛要用龙虾呢？
结果理想冲到他家。
然后直接在他的电脑上。
给他安装上了智能体。
然后说你就用一次。
你就试试看
你看行不行
要试完之后
结果那个哥们自己去买Token去了。
自己就去开始用了。
我觉得听他们这个节目。
挺有意思的
但是听完之后
你不要哈哈一笑
你听完之后
你可以去思考一下。
就是这些事情
在你的身上
你能不能去验证出来。
你能不能去
把他落实到位
就直接运用
所以我当时就在想。
如果说我将来要去。
布置这种智能体的话。
Windows他的生态。
确实是不太合适
你说买一个什么MacBook Neo。
那肯定也是不合适。
所以直接冲M5
对吧？
直接冲MacBook M5。
芯片最好
然后也是带AI的优化。
它的芯片带AI优化。
那就毫无疑问
也不是说多么的鬼。
现在我看价格降完之后。
也就616002。
就可以买到M5 512G了。
对吧？
在磨多多上面
所以这两天我再考虑。
就下单
下单直接给他购买。
我们家买东西
有一个特别有意思的现象。
就是我这个人嘴呢？
有比较快
其实买了
把它藏起来
也没人知道
但是我总是想跟我老婆。
沟通一下
我就知道我不能说。
我一说完之后
我媳妇就讲
我媳妇特别讨厌
我买电子产品
我媳妇说
你想买笔记本是吧？
你现在笔记本
到底能不能用啊？
我就能用啊？
那你这样子
你把你这个笔记本给我卖了。
人或者放公司
你不要给我拿回来。
就是我们家东西
我桌子上面已经摆满了。
他说你告诉我
你这个笔记本买回来你放哪。
你没有地方可放
对吧？
你除非就放在你的。
书房里面
你一天都不拿出来。
你但凡有一天要拿出来。
我必须要把你那个。
另外一个笔记本给扔了。
也能理解
就像买房子一样的。
我说我觉得我们家房子小。
他说那行
那行随你买多大的。
你买了房子之后
打扫卫生你来打扫。
所以他看房间看到的是。
这个房间越大
打扫的压力越大
我看房子看的是
这个房间越多
我可以把它变成我。
我喜欢弹吉他对吧？
他变成我的弹吉他。
然后在家里面健身。
这个地方是可以我用来办公。
私密空间
他一个房间
我一个房间
我们可以都是同时去办公。
他去研究对吧？
研究基金
研究股票
我去研究车
研究邪稿
但是不行
他说你不要跟我想那么多。
不可能的事情
家里面正常住的话。
就一百二一百三
肯定是够了
三十一厅就够了
将来孩子要是出去上学了。
两个房间就已经够了。
要那么多房间干嘛呢？
对不对
客厅不能用吗？
书房你一个
我一个
对不对
两个可能少了
就是书房一个
然后一个人在卧室去办公。
对不对也就行了
搞那么多房间干什么呢？
所以我讲的有点绕的远了。
我们就拉回来继续聊。
就是说
现在大的环境下
其实大家买车还是比较偏理性的。
但是今年的这么多的酒戏上市。
其实我说句实在话。
我就觉得在买酒戏的人群里面。
我看到很多是不太理性的。
就是说他到底需不需要酒戏。
其实中国人买车
其实全世界都一样。
大家买车更多的是什么？
是升级
是改善
就是说我要去看我现在有什么痛点。
我是没有被解决掉的。
我研究来研究去
我发现好像只有到了旗舰车型。
它才能把我的很多的这些痛点给解决掉。
空间的痛点
豪华的痛点
什么大气
气场
这种表面
这种装面子的痛点。
然后功能性的痛点。
舒适度的痛点
好像都能解决掉
讲的不是废话
旗舰车型那么多的最新的技术。
下放到这些
比较下放
就是投放到旗舰车型上。
它肯定能解决
但是问题在于
这个费用也不低
而且你想想看
像L9 Lewis。
包括我们前面讲的ES9。
未来的
包括像蚊姐M9
像这些车型
你要知道
你怎么停
我就很纠结这个问题点。
我首先在节目一开始。
我要讲到我的一个观点。
就是我下一次换车。
我肯定是要换主动旋挂。
你不管是800伏的。
还是未来48伏主动旋挂。
我100%
我下一辆车肯定要带主动旋挂。
因为试完之后
我就知道
这个东西绝对是个好东西。
绝对是个好东西
它的驾乘的体验
完全就是代计差
就是两代车型的代计差。
而现在现在
原车数据实在话
智能驾驶是一块
已经
我觉得没有那么大的差距了。
而且通过OTA的后期不停的。
更新换代
各个品牌
特别是主流品牌
已经把这件事情
研究的非常的透了。
无非就是在这个大方向上。
如何就像我们之前。
聊小鹏的这个
二代的VLA一样。
就如何让他通过
这一个完全正确的路径。
大家一个跑的快
一个跑的慢
对不对
如何让他变得
更加的像老四季一样。
更加的有活人感
无非就是这个
看谁的速度更快一点。
谁的拿到的
Clips更多一点。
就像我们讲小米之前说。
我们拿到了多少万个Clips。
就是一些案例
一些这种交通事故。
或者是交通上博弈的案例。
然后我让机器去学习。
慢慢的一点一点的。
我让它更加的成为一个。
完整的智能体
成熟的智能体
但是我想讲的就是。
这台车
这些车全都超过5米2。
我们家楼底下的机械车位。
我还特意问过管家。
管家跟我讲说
最多最多
不能超过5米2
你哪怕超一点点
可能勉勉强强
但是你要说你是5米3。
或者是你像他是5米255。
5255毫米的车厂。
我那天他数据特意。
我去问了一下
就根本就停不了
一停的话
整个那一层的机械车位。
就动不了了
它会报警的
那个红色的报警灯。
就会哇哇哇直叫
所以
这就是个最现实的问题。
我要如果把我的
Avita卖掉
我去换L9 Liwis。
那我就明显
我停不了这个车位。
我这个车位
已经是交了两年的停车费了。
我怎么办
我停到外面
然后再跟我的车位的房东。
跟他说
我说对不起
我提前
我不租了
这都是很麻烦的事情。
所以
每一个人有每个人。
特殊的情况
就不是说这车
适合所有的人
你包括大车
这么大个车子
我的Avita11。
有的时候
我媳妇还能偶尔开一开。
你搞个5米2
5米3的车
那媳妇摸都不敢摸。
而且它车宽
车宽是2米
你想想看
车宽2米
长度了
你宽度
高度一般没什么问题。
你就宽度
一般的这种斩车位。
你也不一定能停得进去。
是不是
但是我们回到
刚刚讲的理想
L9
L9在二年当年上市之后。
像这种大体量的车。
而且是大体量的新能源车。
它其实做到了一点什么？
就是它让中国的男人。
买这个车
大多数家庭
其实都是男性做决策。
大部分的中国的男人。
他从原来
手上有个四五十万。
它基本就是必选BBA。
那么从这样的一个逻辑里面。
这样的一个主流的观点里面。
它跳脱出来了
我四五十万
不需要再去选BBA了。
我新能源车里面
我可以选未来
我可以选理想
是不是
新能源车其实
早些年它要干的事情。
就是这个
它的旗舰版
或者说
它的这种相对比较高价位的。
四五十万价位的车型。
其实做的就这件事情。
就让你知道
你现在除了BBA之外。
你有第二个选择
而且这个事情
从现在来看是做成了。
对不对
是做成了
包括后来的鸿蒙制型。
文件的M7
M8
M9这些车
它明显是做成了
这个其实跟手机的逻辑非常像。
早年拿个iPhone在路上。
你还有点小炫耀的感觉。
你现在买个iPhone在路上。
你没有任何的感觉。
你包括后来
为什么小米卖的那么好。
用小米的人
人家根本心里面
没有说
好像你用iPhone有多么了不起。
对吧？
小米为发烧而生
买个小米的旗舰机。
它拿着用着
它觉得挺好的
没有任何问题
甚至包括Vivo。
OPPO
早年其实我也有一些刻板的印象。
我觉得Vivo
OPPO都是什么人用。
都是一些可能学生在用。
都是一些可能不懂手机的。
就是好看
或者说当时他不是拍照。
特别的自带美颜吗？
我觉得可能是一些小姐姐。
他们比较喜欢用
结果到了后来
我手上Vivo的折叠屏。
X4的
用的挺好的吗？
我觉得挺好的
包括
你看我这个Vivo。
当时我觉得最好的几个点。
第一个
它这个操作系统
我用到现在也不卡。
而且也没有什么bug。
而且经常更新
然后第二个
它的服务也挺好的。
你想我的内屏膜
虽然说已经是换过两次了。
但是我这换的两次。
第一次换是
好像是三年之内
还是两年之内
是可以免费更换两次吧？
我第一次更换用的是免费。
然后第二次
它是在你第一次更换的基础上。
九十天之内
如果出问题的话
你再更换
不使用
它的原先治保期内的更换次数。
结果
我当时这个膜
正好是过了大概
十来天吧？
七八天还是十来天。
我当时眼瞅着这个膜。
已经开始出问题了。
一开始是气泡
然后变成折痕
然后一点一点往上延伸。
它只要出现裂痕了。
基本上就止不住了。
就有点像我们前挡玻璃。
车辆的前挡玻璃
出现了一个小裂痕。
你要是不管它
它可能时间久了之后。
就会越裂越长
越裂越长
所以为什么有些老司机。
它也不去修
就怎么操作呢？
它在裂痕的上下的两头。
会打两个孔
主动去打两个孔
这两个孔就是为了让它。
不会裂痕延伸
对不对
这个蛮聪明的
但是这个其实我觉得也蛮危险的。
因为它本身
玻璃的硬力已经是不一样了。
一旦要是如果受外部的冲击。
一旦要是比方说
内外的温度温差
到了一定的程度的话。
它都有可能会裂开。
会碎开
还是比较危险的
所以玻璃如果是小坑化。
我觉得去做一个简单的修补。
是没有问题的
我曾经在节目里面提过。
像这种修补的话
你也不用去CSD。
你就在你掏出手机。
用那个大众点评
然后你就搜玻璃修复。
那你基本上就能搜到。
在你们当地应该会有。
这个叫服药玻璃的。
售后服务维修站
你就给它打个电话。
它会跟你要你的
车辆的车价号
或者像如果燃油车的话。
可能会要个发动机号。
那么你把车价号发动机号。
其实拍个行驶证就行吗？
你拍个行驶证
你给它看
前挡玻璃
或者后挡玻璃
价格大概是多少钱。
这个报价是比较准确的。
而且它是包工爆料。
工事费跟玻璃的费用。
你跟它约个时间
人家肯定是货提前调好。
去了以后基本上当天力等可取。
但也不可能那么快。
就是你去了之后
周围稍微逛一逛
吃一吃喝一喝
去商场里面钻一圈。
基本上给它几个小时。
就给你装好了
非常简单
下玻璃装玻璃
清除交代
然后密封
这些都不是特别难的一件事情。
所以不用傻乎乎的。
说一定要回到3S店。
然后3S店给你报个价。
然后走保险
我觉得意义不大
那当然了
你要如果说
你能走保险
那你也能够接受第二年保费上涨。
那你就正常走
所以我们就讲一个题外话。
其实说到底
就是像酒戏的车型。
我觉得绝大多数的人。
你在买之前一定要考虑的一个点。
就是你实际的使用的人。
以及你实际使用的环境。
这两件事情是非常重要的。
如果说这台车子90%就是你一个人开。
然后你周末
你可以把它一车多用。
当成是个MPV
因为它六座
家里人如果是满载。
三排座
你这种应用场景是比较多。
那我觉得没有问题。
你一个人开
也不讲究说
别人觉得是大车
不适应
这些都没有问题
因为现在基本上
像这个级别的车
一般都会带后轮转向。
所以它的转弯半径。
我觉得还是挺好的。
就在路口
我觉得转半径比我的车。
一般都小
基本上一把就直接调过来了。
还是非常不错
不用担心说
这个大车会开得非常不舒服。
现在就是越是到这种大的车型。
越是到这种旗舰版的车型。
包括像一些接近于全尺寸。
或者就是全尺寸的SUV。
它一般是讲究什么呢？
叫做给你大的体量感。
但不给你大车的体验感。
叫给你大车的体量感。
但是不给你大车的体验感。
这个东西说白了
都是科技与很活
白了都是要给你加一些科技的。
所以这些东西
科技的东西加多了之后。
好处是什么呢？
就是你肯定用的顺手。
一切都会有电子电器去给你做辅助。
包括悬挂
包括转向
包括像我们讲麻后面说。
先空转向这种
后轮转向这种
它确实很方便
但是你总觉得少了一点什么东西。
但少了什么东西呢？
其实我感觉就是
从我们当年学驾照的时候。
就是那种机械挂挡。
这种感觉
对吧？
机械按键
这种感觉
这种感觉没有了
你包括现在800V的这种主动旋挂。
我用完之后
虽然它非常好
如履平地
我今天重点
我就想讲这个800V的主动旋挂。
我一会儿后期
我会再展开来跟大家聊。
它是真的是如履平地。
它是什么感受
就是你跑山的时候。
正常情况下
你肯定是左摇右晃。
它不晃
几乎不晃
稳的是一塌糊涂
你说掂波路段
减速砍
那种坑坑瓦瓦的飞铺桩路面。
车子里面肯定是
剩下肯定是有抛跳的。
几乎没有
就是
就过去了
你包括在城区
我们踩刹车
我们去加速
车辆正常有抚养
很正常吗？
几乎没有
坐在车子里面
就跟坐高铁没什么区别。
稳如老狗
有人讲说
三刀有你说的那么夸张吗？
你这今天是不是在。
舔这个理想的L9。
我告诉你
我舔的不是理想L9。
我是在舔800伏的主动旋卦。
但是我回头再想一想。
一旦有一天
我换到了800伏的主动旋卦。
我可能真的我就回不去了。
所以我现在特别的怀念。
就是这种被动旋卦。
就是这种什么前卖不去。
后多连感
我的车现在还不带空旋。
这种感觉
我说句实在话
开一天是一天了
兄弟们
珍惜这种感觉
珍惜这种你跟车辆旋卦之间的。
我们讲叫互动的感觉。
这个老哥
我觉得用不了多久。
如果把旋卦当成老哥。
你就跟他说再见了。
你包括后面
他其实这套就是800伏主动旋卦。
他也是通过空旋CDC。
一整套的这些配件。
整合在一起
然后给一套底盘的逻辑。
对吧？
他是一整套的整合系统。
所以怎么讲
有些时候
可能我现在四十多岁年纪大了。
今天这好像是我的生日。
5月14号
我在录音的时候
我还在思考这个问题。
人到了这个过生日的时间点。
有的时候也蛮赶处的。
一转意
将来就是活到八二多岁。
90岁
我的人生也过半了。
我是这二八你算是。
半截土已经埋在生死上的人了。
是不是
半截土都埋在生死上的人了。
总是会在想
他如果一旦要是过去了。
他这种体验一旦要是没有了。
我还算是一个比较拥抱未来的人。
将来开车都是这种800伏主动旋挂。
48伏主动旋挂
是很舒服
但是我们真的要的是这种感觉吗？
这是一个哲学问题。
对吧？
这是个哲学问题
只能坐舱了
然后将来L3 L4都是自动驾驶了。
再配上这样的一个主动旋挂。
我的妈呀？
这不就等于是坐在高铁里面吗？
还有冰箱裁垫大沙发。
是不是
所以我们讲理想L9当年。
二二年上了之后
为什么后来一直卖的好。
他其实最主要就是。
他设置了一个场景。
就是一个中产家庭。
周末带孩子带老人。
然后自驾录营回老家。
就这些人到底需要什么？
他其实想得非常的明白。
他想得非常的明白。
当年那个环境下
二零二年那个环境下。
豪华品牌传统的这些BBA。
他看不起这种路线。
就是你心失力
现在搞什么冰箱裁垫大沙发。
什么奶爸
你搞的什么玩意
他奶爸
奶爸就一定要开你的车了。
你看我的奔驰不是奶爸。
看我的宝马不是奶爸。
你一个破真诚
你这真诚有什么淘汰的技术。
我大众根本就看不上。
是不是
之前大众的CEO不是说了吗？
真诚是淘汰的技术。
然后当时的心失力。
很多都是在卷唇垫。
很多也没有下场做真诚。
然后那个时候的唇垫。
还在卷一些性能方面的事情。
卷续航
然后卷车内的科技感。
然后有一些买六座的。
当时不是也是主打六座。
七座
六座
那么六座这一块
MPV的市场
其实又是一个非常小众的市场。
不够主流
所以你看当年L9。
就是理想刚上的第一代。
它其实在那个年代切进来的时候。
它相当于
我们可以讲
它就是披了一个蓝海。
不去跟那些纯电的去竞争。
然后看能不能从BBA的传统的。
豪车里面抢一块肉过来。
是不是
我去定义这样的一个市场。
那么回到现在2026年。
才刚刚过去34年的时间。
问件M9
藤氏N9
这个未来ES9
零客900
极客9X
我的妈呀？
我还没说完
一堆的高端性的原车。
已经是进入到市场。
开始神仙打架了
所以你说L9
Livis卖559800。
贵不贵
这是预售价
那我相信
真实上是肯尼哈
会再往下调一点
贵不贵
我觉得不重要
这个不是我说了算。
也不是你说了算
是买车的人
他说了算
如果说他已经是买到这个级别了。
而且之前看的就是ES9。
看的就是这个M9的Ultimate。
就是看的这些版本的车型。
人家本来预算就是六七十万。
现在看到一个559800。
甚至于他看那两台车的时候。
他可能都会觉得说这么大个车。
体量大不一定是他喜欢的。
他可能觉得说
反而5米25
这个长度包括3米1。
这个轴距
我觉得OK啊？
没什么问题
空间都OK
再看一看
整个的车机
支架
再看看他四颗激光雷达。
然后刚刚说的800V主动旋挂。
再去试一试
冰箱采建大沙发
从里到外
底盘
支架 硬件 电池 续航。
现在都是420公里的CRTC续航了。
对吧？
72.7度电
然后再看看800V5C的电池。
充电速度也变快了。
电子电池架构
这些全部从里到外都升级了。
50多万
在他来预算范围内。
有什么问题呢？
我觉得没啥问题
是不是
所以我们前面
三十多分钟
就光是第一段
讲了三十多分钟
我的天的
我们后面加快点速度。
我今天分了六段
给大家好好聊
讲一讲这个车
一些简单的
或者说外形内饰的一些。
硬件上的一些变化。
这个车子
其实你要从外形上来看。
我讲一讲细节上的变化。
其实轮廓变化不大。
你一眼就能看出来。
还是L9造型
没什么变化
轮廓变化不大
主要是在于
它已经形成了一个品牌里。
它就是
从大到小
复刻
大号的L系列
然后中号的小号的76。
按照这个逻辑去做。
它形成品牌里
它也不敢随便动
轮廓变化不大
但是它的前面
有几个细节
第一个
它的新环灯
原来是2米刚上的时候。
大家看到还是蛮震撼的。
但是现在大家都在。
多新环灯
所以就不细起了
现在把新环灯
稍微拉长了一点
官方讲是2米3
实际上
我是没有太多的感觉。
这个可能要对比
就两台车
老款新款放在一起。
你才能知道
但是新环灯
有个最大的变化是什么？
它开始有三种颜色了。
原来一直都是单色的。
现在是三种颜色
你包括
车辆唤醒
包括驻车状态
包括各种情况下
它会有三种颜色
我记得应该是
白色
黄色和蓝色
三色
那么它的前面
有一些细节变化是什么的。
就是它的下方的进气口。
因为它毕竟
它没有前备箱
它是真诚
所以它要散热
原来的进气口
它是比较宽的
它是中间一块
两边还有两侧
它现在是两边
全部封闭了
然后中间只有一小块。
它的整个面积变小了。
然后简单
它的前旋
会变得更短
然后机盖
会变得更高
所以这就是我曾经讲的。
就是旗舰机车型
它一定要做宽高比。
一定要做宽高比
你像大陆虎
大陆虎
为什么给人感觉
气势非常的强
包括像
老斯莱斯的库里南。
就是因为它的
你看它引擎盖
架得非常的高
然后它整个车
宽高比做得非常的好。
再加上短前旋
所以这台车子给你感觉。
它的前脸的气场会很强。
那么L9李维斯
它就是按照这个方向走。
或者说整个的L9。
这一代的车型
新一代的车型
就往这个方向走
但是它的尾部你会发现。
它的后肘
它往后看
你去看它的整个地柱在往后。
第一个是比较垂直的。
比较纯平的
原来我看它的尾部。
还有一些折角
但是现在是几乎纯平。
而且它的后尾部的。
这个后肘
就是后轮的中心点。
到它的后背箱的顶点。
这个位置是延伸比较长的。
你去看鹿虎
其实也是这样子设计的。
鹿虎的大懒慎
你看它的前旋比较短。
但是车屁股
就会稍微延伸出来一点。
这都是往这种旗舰车型上去靠。
而且我之前
我记得有一次车站。
我理想就在我旁边去看。
我记得当时是看鹿虎的心脉。
我记得当时是
它就很兴奋
它就是个鹿虎车迷。
它对于鹿虎的设计。
它是非常非常看好的。
它叫鹿虎车迷
或叫鹿虎设计方面的一个小粉丝。
如果你要说雷军是保尔杰的粉丝。
我可以非常确定的讲。
这个理想就是鹿虎的粉丝。
所以它车上包括它内饰的设计。
你仔细想一想
它其实很多的一些细节。
皮质的包裹
内饰的那种圆润的设计。
很多都是按照鹿虎的方向来。
鹿虎其实也是很早在内饰。
做那种急减的高级感。
也是按照这个方向去做。
你这么一讲
你其实你心里就
我就想通了
好像是有那种感觉。
是吧？
所以我刚刚讲的
新环灯
然后进气口
然后前轴
对吧？
前旋 后旋
然后包括它的整个的低柱。
尾部的这些设计
它都有一些变化
但是这些变化在我看来。
都是一些小的细节的变化。
而这台车
如果我不跟你讲
销售很有可能会有一点给你漏掉。
你到Sense店去看的话。
你会发现
这台车前后左右
你看不到它的前保杠。
后保杠上面有那种。
就是打孔的雷达
我们讲叫超声波雷达。
因为我们知道
车辆正常的话
倒车
或者说是停车的时候。
你会听到有那种滴滴滴滴滴滴滴滴。
这个是靠超声波雷达。
去做探测障碍物
这个车没有了
那没有了
它靠什么呢？
它靠UWB
什么叫经常感知
就我们知道
现在很多的新能源车。
是可以
你只要带个手机
然后你靠近车辆
车辆解锁
然后你离开车辆
车辆自动上锁
那我的Alvita。
我一直用的是这个。
我两台手机我都绑定了嘛？
那么靠近了解锁
离开了就直动上锁。
有的时候特别有意思。
我忘了锁了 因为我蓝牙没有开。
但是这个很少见 如果你蓝牙没有开 你车根本就解不了锁嘛？
你很少会遇到什么情况呢 就是你上车把蓝牙给关了。
你比方说我的车子是自动连蓝牙的嘛 上了车之后。
我想去听书
在我的手机上去拨那个听书的一些软件。
结果我拨听书我就发现。
车载的蓝牙的声音都偏小。
那我就不想用车载的蓝牙去通过我的手机播放。
然后车里面的音响放。
我就直接把蓝牙断开 断开 我就把我的手机。
为什么我车上会有一个吸盘的支架。
有人说你的这个车机系统不好用吗？
有的时候拍视频会给大家看到我的车上有个支架对吧？
不是我的车机不好用 而Vita11这个浑萌车机很好用。
我是在有的时候
比方说我听一些
视频平台的声音
听一些声音 或者说我听一些比方说小宇宙。
它浑萌系统里面它没有。
它没有 但是那个节目只在小宇宙上有。
那怎么办
那我就把手机放着 可手机没地方放。
手机你放在那个杯架的位置。
无线充电的位置
那个声音是从你的右下角。
传播过来的 我觉得听的不是很舒服。
所以我觉得在前掌上面吸了一个吸盘。
我把手机架在上面。
然后直接播放 锁个屏。
就在我的右前方
耳朵听这个声音就很清楚。
所以有的时候我也不是完全在用我的车机。
我也是在用我的手机去听节目。
也很舒服
我只是获取信息嘛？
对不对 所以什么车载音响多少个喇叭。
你说像这个车子
你包含投掷音响一共33个喇叭。
我听下来我觉得也就那么回事。
也就那么回事
它不是说不好
它的音响是更偏向于解析力。
以及它的高频会比较好。
我怀疑可能理想本人喜欢听流行音乐。
所以因此它听来听去都是按照流行音乐的那种。
人声更加的突出
还原度更加的高
但其实我可能偏向于听节奏快一点的。
我喜欢听摇滚 对吧？
我可能到现在听的还是比较老派的。
我喜欢听Bruepop 英伦摇滚。
什么Oasis Blah 包括什么Ridu Head。
我喜欢听这些
但是你包括我还喜欢听一些硬摇。
你听一些像早年的我喜欢听Smash Pumpings。
就是那个叫什么碎南瓜。
可能我发音不要做。
包括我喜欢听当年的Gunshan Rose。
这些什么Don't Cry Tonight。
我听Nawana。
就是这些
有的时候怀疑我不知道听什么歌了。
我就开始去瞎找
找我之前上学的时候听那些歌。
听说《马里联曼森》
什么什么听skidrow。
穷街
去听那些skidnaught活节。
我就反正到处乱听。
因为我以前在大学。
我主持就是欧美音乐。
然后在大学广播台主持欧美音乐。
那时候放歌放的那个学校的领导投诉。
说你放的什么歌啊？
天天就跟猫叫一样。
因为摇滚乐到后面就是唱到高潮部分。
就思候嘛？
就真唱
基本上都不用假声的。
就像猫叫
然后呢那个喇叭又是针对着。
这个老年退休的这些教职工的那个宿舍。
所以那些老职工就特别抱怨。
就跟他们领导去投诉。
所以让我的
然后说你节目这场主持。
你还是放点流行音乐吧？
不要放那些特别吵的。
对吧？
这学生也不一定爱听。
所以那几年
那几年我觉得南京十万大学的。
这个摇滚乐的启蒙。
我还是做了一点贡献的。
好
我们还是讲到这个车。
想到哪讲到哪
其实我是觉得是什么呢？
就是车大是面子
停车是日子
就是这个车子
它用了UWB之后。
它是个大车
但是呢？
你说它真正有没有。
实质性的改善这个车的。
比方说这个雷达的灵敏度啊？
或者说探测障碍物的高度啊？
你比方说超级贸易达。
可能有一些障碍物过低过高。
它不一定能能就是探测得到。
这个东西
许说实话
就算你知道了
你也不可能感知到具体细节。
你知道它是个好东西。
它一定包括抗干扰的能力。
探测障碍物的准确度啊？
各方面都很好
感受不到
你只是知道唯一的一个点是什么？
车上没有开孔
你看不到这些孔了。
因为它只是用了UWB的这样一个技术。
它不需要去开槽去装这个超级贸易达。
所以更加有这种立体感。
就仅此而已
那么这个车的整体的姿态。
我觉得还是比较偏向于旗舰SUV。
但是跟M9包括未来的ES9。
它的体量还是要略微的差一点点。
就是体积各方面
明显能看得出来
整体的体量稍微差一点。
就有点像就比较说。
我觉得可能跟我跟詹姆斯站在一起。
有点夸张了
就可能我跟一个身高1米9。
1米85的人
是体格又比较壮的人站在一起。
这个可能会有一点差别。
大概就这么大一个差别。
我1.75
我跟他站在一起
我身体又是偏瘦
对不对
所以明显他要是打南下背打。
打低位
那我肯定是防不了的嘛？
是不是
那詹姆斯这种级别。
那个是凯雷德
那个不是什么M9啊这种。
那就更夸张了
所以我觉得
这台车适不适合你。
你还是要在车子前面去看。
你不要在网上看
网上它是没有对比的。
你在车子的整个的。
这种非常有立体感觉的车子面前。
你就知道这种体量适不适合你。
买这种车型的人基本不是刚需。
都是进行升级去替换。
去满足自己的一个。
就是怎么样的
就出行的品质的一个需求。
这个很关键
所以它的什么800V 5C充电速度这些。
我建议你不要那么早去入手。
你可以去看一看
相关的实际第一批提升的用户。
他们CRTC420公里续航到底是能开到多少公里。
它的综合续航1650公里。
满油满电
那肯定有人会去测嘛？
它真实的测出来是多少。
然后它的充电速度是多少。
我觉得这个是很关键的。
电池确实很大72.7度电。
那么现在这种旗舰级的大车。
不管是插捆还是增尘。
都是叫做大电池
而且是带大油箱
油箱也没有缩水
所以大电池大油箱。
那就相当于这个车子。
其实整体的重量就肯定是不会低的。
所以我当时看到这台车的轮胎。
我当时还问了米其林的人。
他因为22寸的轮胎是。
Levis的相当于是高配车型的。
他还有个21寸的轮胎。
包括轮胎的颜色也不一样。
它是那种千灰色
包括Levis的门框上的视条。
也是千灰色
但那个千灰色是有点偏亮的。
但轮圈的千灰色是暗色的。
它的一些细节的调整。
包括它的一些整体的设计。
你在选装轮骨的时候。
你会发现跟普通版本也会有差别。
所以说这台车整体适不适合你。
我觉得你一定要去知道。
Levis的版本跟普通的L9。
它到底有哪些不一样的点。
你不管是情绪价值上面的。
还是说实用价值上面的。
这些东西如果都能切中你。
我觉得有70%左右能够切中你。
这车子基本上你就可以把它订为你的。
这个备选的方案之一了。
如果说六成七成以上。
或者有些功能完全没有。
也解决不了是你必须要的。
那这个就你可以直接放弃。
因为久期的车型还是很多的。
所以我也不是说一定要推这个车。
只是我体验完了跟大家分享。
还有不好意思
这两天感冒确实是不是很舒服。
还没完全好
讲到感冒我跟大家再讲个小插曲。
我出差回来发现感冒越来越严重了。
上期节目讲着讲着后面嗓子都哑了。
我就发现还是要磕药。
我得去买点感冒药。
就完全靠扛
我这40多岁的身体扛。
也不一定能一时半会能扛得好。
那天晚上去买药
结果我发现家里没人闻口。
因为回来就比较晚。
10点多钟药房都关门了。
我都已经放弃了
突然我想了一下
不是有那种美团买药吗？
我就上网我就搜了一下美团买药。
我就发现再过两个红绿灯右转。
有一家药房
它是可以送货的
那个药房在线都能送货。
那就说明开门
那我骑个电动车吃一下。
我就过去了
过去之后发现果然是开着个门。
然后我是用GPT。
我当时问了一下
我说我大概是个什么情况。
比方说我流清鼻涕。
然后我就感觉有点。
白天就感觉有点疲惫有点累。
然后不咳嗽
但是嗓子有点不舒服。
有点那种刺痒痒的感觉。
他就直接给我分析说病毒是感冒。
然后推荐我第一个是吃这个叫做。
叫做什么来着
新康泰克
他当时说的是叫做什么安分加纳米片什么东西的。
那不就是康泰克吗？
然后再买一个叫什么西地点韩片。
讲的都是专业术语。
我说你能不能说人话。
到底买什么？
他说你就买个康泰克。
再买一个滑速片
我说那一说人话不就行了吗？
讲半天
所以我就去买
到了店里面之后特别搞笑。
这个店员当时就拿了两盒给我。
说我是多少钱
我都准备刷卡了
刷了这个医保了
他跟我讲说这两盒六十多块钱。
我说六十多块钱
我就把手机给他看。
我说你们店在网上才三二多块钱。
他说网上有补贴
说现在这个药基本上就做不下去了。
就太绝了
他说那你不行
你在网上下单
然后我说我看了一下那个盒子。
我说那也不对
你这个是网上那个是十片装。
你这个是二十片装。
他说有十片装
他特别有意思
他把十片装放到仓库里面。
然后把二十片装放在那个架子上面。
所以当时我一开始我选的是三二多块钱的。
后来我把二十片装去掉。
我变成了十片装
所以你网上一撕康泰克。
你会撕出两个结果。
我当时一看这两个有什么区别。
一个是十片一个是三十片。
然后我再看一天吃三颗。
我觉得像我这个毛病三天基本上就好了。
我对我自己的免疫能力还是比较自信的。
我说十颗颗三天就差不多了。
他给我个二十片的。
你们有没有发现
每个人家里面都一堆的药。
很多都是过期的
我之前出去旅游
我去中国台湾旅游的时候。
那次我是拉肚子不舒服。
非常严重
后来我在中国台湾的。
当时是花莲还是哪个地方。
我当时去他们的医院去看病。
那个哥们特别有意思。
我游戏节目他说过。
那个哥们当时来过苏州。
他看我的身份证
当时我身份证没有用。
我当时说是因为什么原因给他看的。
好像不是身份证
好像是港澳台的证。
他说你是南京的
我说对
我去过苏州
我说你不会是去明基医院吧？
我想起来
我当时拿出了一张明基医院的卡给他看。
那个哥们在江苏苏州。
他竟然在明基医院实习过。
工作过
我当时跟那哥们聊天聊得很有意思。
他穿那个篮球鞋批个白大挂。
我说你这明显就是下了班直接去球场了。
他说我下了班我就去打球。
你看人家生活过得多自在。
当时我想讲的是什么？
当时中国台湾的药叫医院里面。
他的配药
就是我给你吃三天。
我就给你三天的药。
那个药是剪出来的。
吃完是正正好
一片不多一片不少。
但我们都是整合整合的去给。
我就想不通这一点。
那天后来我问他
我说我不要20片的。
我要10片的
然后他给我一个10片的。
他说10片的你在店里买的话。
就是48
刚刚那个是50多。
差10块钱
我说48
你网上就20多吗？
他说你就在网上下单。
你就到店去
所以我就在美团的线上。
下单20多块钱
补贴补了我10几块钱。
我的天呐
然后店员就有点
也不叫不开心
可能他有点觉得
哥们估计你就是个牛。
你没多少钱
就这点钱你还要省。
我在想
你看不起我就看不起我。
我又不会少一块肉。
对不对
那本质上来讲
我就是为了
线上买跟线下买有什么区别。
东西都是一样的东西。
平台有补贴
羊毛为什么不好
是吧？
我讲的有点就是题外话了。
反正有点感冒
这个嗓音不是特别好。
大家多多见谅
就讲一点身边事
给大家来聊一聊
好我们再讲一讲
车的里面的一些体验。
这个车的前排
最大的变化是什么的。
就是他把原来的L9的双连屏。
两块15连7的屏幕。
它是拼到一起的
现在变成了一整块的29英寸的屏。
其实我觉得没什么必要。
为什么我觉得没什么必要。
第一个
它成本肯定是上去了。
对吧？
第二个
我没有觉得
之前的两块屏
跟现在的一整块屏。
有多大的区别
你作为主驾室来讲的话。
你用的那一块区域。
那不就是八张大的那边一块区域吗？
你能怎样
你就算是播个视频啥的。
你怎么样
你主驾室能有多长时间在里面看视频。
你开车的时候又不能看。
停着的时候
当然是在二排
你二排还有西顶屏。
对吧？
你二排西顶屏
你也可以看
你为什么一定要在前排看的。
所以前排
包括副驾室的那块屏幕。
副驾室的屏
现在等于是跟主驾的屏是一整块了。
副驾室的屏幕
你分两块屏
一样吗？
成本还更低
你原来15.7英寸两块。
用了那么多年
一定是它的供应商体系。
它的渠道打得非常通了。
它开这个模具
它卖了那么多辆
你想它为什么内饰全部同质化。
为什么外观全部同质化。
就是为了它这种
我们讲理想还不算是特别大的公司。
它这种体量级的公司。
它一定是要把它
所有的零配件压榨到最极限。
怎么压榨到最极限的成本。
说白了就是要量大。
为什么很多的车企要动不动说。
我们预售订单是多少。
小定多少
小定的订单都非常夸张。
为什么呀？
就给供应链看的
说白了
就给那些供应链看的。
但是现在供应链也不是傻。
现在的供应链
我那天跟一个厂家聊。
厂家的厂方的负责采购的人跟我聊。
他说现在供应链就直接给你谈什么？
就是你每个月的销量是多少。
三千台五千台一万台。
你先给我订这个
完了之后三千五千一万。
我按照你的实际的销量。
采购量
我给你订价格
浮动价格
对吧？
能完成
我们就要让这个价格来。
不能完成
合同里面签的好好的。
就是你必须给我补。
要么就是补钱
要么你给我把这个配件全部拉回去。
拉回去的概率不高。
那大多数都是补钱。
对吧？
你给我把这个钱给我补上。
所以现在供应链也不是傻。
当然了
这必须是强势的供应链。
强势的供应链
我前两天看了一个新闻。
说这个利訊经密
就是给苹果代工的。
所以现在设了两家公司。
马上要大力的去加入到新能源。
汽车的供应链体系。
要做Tel 1的。
就是一级供应商
我得管
这可是大佬
我觉得利讯经密进入到汽车圈。
去做供应商
不亚于小米进入到汽车圈去造新能源。
我们拭目以待
有机会我们再慢慢聊。
可能有些朋友对利讯经密。
还不是特别了解
他收了一个叫做惊喜国际。
然后又去拿下了
还有一个公司叫什么？
叫做德国莱尼
德国莱尼持股比例。
从50.1%大幅提升到74.9%。
这个不能叫做拿下。
简单说是绝对空股。
所以说他后面是要进入到汽车产业链。
去做智能底盘选价。
这是我们今天讲的800副。
因为国内这块基本上是空白。
没有统一交付的
基本上还是车企再去做。
然后包括他还会去做自动领域。
所以他会切这种智能底盘赛道。
利讯经密
大家可以关注一下。
这个赛道我觉得后期还是非常有市场的。
很多有些听有听我的节目之后。
会去根据我的给出的信息去买股票。
这里我还是要提醒一点。
我给出了一些信息。
可能在之前行业内的人已经早就知道了。
而且这些信息也不是什么特别新的。
或者是小道消息
所以股市有风险入市要谨慎。
我透露的任何消息绝对不是去引导大家。
或者是提倡大家去买股票的。
虽然有些人听完之后买了。
还真的挣到钱了
但是我想再提醒一句。
我只是一个汽车媒体。
把我知道的一些消息在我的节目当中。
分享给大家
精彩而已
我们刚刚讲到他的车机。
其实理想的车机
意识是我们圈内公认的。
不管是从操作逻辑也好。
还是实际的美感也好。
它的这套系统更像苹果的。
不管是MacBook还是苹果的手机系统。
它更像它的整个的原生态。
它的高级感还是非常不错的。
这个有仪说一样
用过理想的车机的人应该都知道。
反应速度
它的菜单逻辑
它的使用的体验
整体还是非常不错的。
但是你说其他的车机不好吗？
也不是不好
现在的主流车机基本上我觉得。
大部分会按照像华为的那一套的。
车机的系统体系去延伸。
比如说下面是Doclan最早。
然后大家都是这么样去应用的。
然后Doclan里面土标可以进行去设置。
然后有些是以导航为主界面。
就你不管怎么切
你回到原界面之后。
导航是主界面
那么还有一些就是壁纸。
还有一些就是比如说。
车辆的智能驾驶SR的画面。
就是显示好多小汽车。
显示你的周围有些什么障碍物。
然后菜单
包括它的功能液
它可以进行定制
大体上玩来玩去就这么个思路。
但是早期很多人的车机系统是非常难用的。
通过后期的迭代
有做的好的我就学嘛？
那么慢慢的
其实我觉得在车机这一块。
各家之间的体验差别也没有那么大了。
因为芯片的供应商就那么几家。
都可以进行采购
系统这一块大家也基本上玩明白了。
怎么样去优化
怎么样更顺手
无非就是什么？
我觉得现在的差别就是。
确确实实各家的这种美感。
什么UI VI的视觉体系的一些设计。
有的土一点
有的确实看上去就很土。
就有点像山寨货
但是有的这种很高级。
包括每一次那个每个页面之间的那种小动画的切换。
感觉确实不一样
这个就是情绪价值了。
对吧？
然后他讲说新款的L9。
它的增加了远目试条。
说非常好看
但是说实话
它的远目试条不是我们看到的那种。
说车里面有大面积的木质的示板。
它不是的
它是在前面的中控台的下方压了一根试条。
是藏在里面的
然后我又是白天试价。
所以我有感受不到它的氛围灯。
所以我觉得这个远目试条的质感可能。
你要在晚上然后打了灯之后。
才能感受得出来
但白天我是没感受出来。
还有包括它的那个座椅。
说什么零型的纹路。
重新设计了它的缝线。
我觉得就没什么好说了。
零型的皮质作业
很多车上都是这样。
但是这里我想讲一个细节。
就是为什么大多数的车辆要用零型的纹路。
零型的纹路你可以理解为。
它有一点像当年我们买运动鞋分窝减震。
我还记得当时的Rebok。
Rebok的分窝减震是当年我第一次了解到。
原来南丘鞋还能有减震。
我当时上小学还是初中。
我当时记得同学就开始买了Rebok。
家里比较有钱
是吧？
父母爷爷都是公务员。
脚上穿着是菲勒的袜子。
然后鞋子就是Nike Adidas。
基本上没有看过他穿这两个牌子以外的鞋。
然后当时穿Rebok。
Rebok对对对。
Rebok是除了这两个牌子以外的。
穿到学校里面非常震撼。
我们当时觉得这根本好羡慕。
我当时就特别羡慕。
我想拥有一双类似这样的鞋子。
所以现在有能力买了。
但是我现在找不到Rebok了。
我现在真的我特别想穿一双Rebok的。
带蜂窝简称的男球鞋。
这是我儿时的一个梦。
但是我现在真的
你现在真让我去买男球鞋。
我最近男球鞋又开始磨的。
有点小坏了
可是我就
那我第一个反应我还是买Nike。
我还是买Nike。
我还是买D0
对吧？
我就这两个牌子二选一。
哎呀？
就是时候这个圆梦也很难。
真的是
而且可能穿上去的感觉。
也不像以前那种感觉了。
是不是
所以他作以为什么是灵形的纹路。
第一个他理论上讲可以延缓塌线。
他可以去书压
人的靠背
对吧？
包括屁股往上一坐。
他是书压
然后他会有一种这种悬浮感。
轻微的一种悬浮感。
可以让他将来的塌线空骨稍微延缓一些。
我觉得这是他的一个比较合理的逻辑。
至于说什么好看不好看。
这个我觉得不是重点。
然后还有理想的内饰。
其实在我看来
他的整体的配色
相对来讲还是比较偏居家风格。
他的内饰风格往好了讲。
其实我刚刚说走路虎路线。
如果是往普通的车上来讲的话。
他其实有点偏向于走这种像日产的路线。
因为日产的车辆基本上都是按照居家风。
因为我们知道居家风是什么意思呢？
就是你们家的墙是不可能刷高保护合度的颜色。
对吧？
你们家的地板也不可能是买那种特别鲜艳的地板。
就是我们在做家庭装饰的时候。
一般是什么？
是上浅下身
很少有人会把地板选浅色。
然后墙壁去贴墙纸贴的特别是。
那就头重脚轻了
一般都是一种下身上浅。
他有个过度色
包括买窗帘也是
窗帘的颜色怎么选。
其实就是看你的墙体的颜色和你的地板的颜色。
能形成一个过度
家里的颜色也不能太多。
不能太跳
因为我办公室刚装了窗帘。
所以我就知道他整体跟我的环境的一个搭配。
也做了一些功课
所以因此他坐进去之后给我的感觉是什么呢？
我觉得就是松弛感。
居家感松弛感
大体上就是这样
有些车不是这样的。
有些车比方说骗运动型的车。
他坐进去之后的感觉是有一种。
不能叫攻击感
就是有一种
就是我上了车后就得踩油门的感觉。
他那种感觉是怎么营造出来呢？
包括你像红色的Star的这种启动按键。
Star的启动按键。
然后方向盘是带打孔的战斗型方向盘。
对吧？
然后车辆的一些功能键。
也是偏向于你的主驾驶这一侧。
完全是为你个人服务的。
然后统装的座椅
坐上去之后
屁股帮帮硬
然后两边是给你的腰腹是收紧的。
然后座椅也是靠背比较的比直。
一切都是那种战斗姿态。
坐上去之后
你的反应就是这车。
我明显就是要开快。
明显就是要跟人去干。
不服就干
但是你想这种车坐上去。
我就想了就是我左边。
哎呀？
这个是皮质
手搭在上面挺舒服。
右边搭着也挺舒服。
很松弛
是这种感觉
所以买车的时候
不是说这车好与不好。
买车你要找
你到底要什么感觉。
你是要你说我喜欢开车。
你喜欢开车
你要找那种偏向于上了车之后。
能找到我想开的感觉。
你说我不开车
我连变道我都难得变。
好
那你找到就是松弛感。
生活感
找这种感觉
那么后排这一块
我觉得没有太多可说的。
无非就是什么呢？
二排左右两个零重力座椅。
然后三排空间也还可以。
因为轴距毕竟超过三米一了。
你说空间能差到哪。
然后三排的座椅
它还有一个功能
是可以把它的座椅角度往后调。
而且它的靠背角度调得还蛮大的。
这一点我想重点的讲。
正常的理解就是上了车。
二排肯定是首选
对吧？
为什么？
因为二排两个是老板座。
这两个座椅
它不但有零重力
而且它功能特别多。
而且二排左右两边的玻璃窗。
它还是隐私玻璃
是EC可调光的隐私玻璃。
三级可调
你调到最深的颜色。
你觉得还不够
你可以旁边还有电动遮阳连。
你可以把遮阳连给它伸上去。
但是我想讲的就是。
二排既是零重力
二排的副驾驶的后侧既是有。
甚至包括脚托
腿托都有
那么二排后面是带脚托。
右后侧是带脚托
既是有这么多功能。
但我想讲
如果一家三口出去玩。
其实如果老妈是坐在三排。
你是坐在二排
或者说比方说孩子。
或者是两家人一起玩。
有另外一家人坐在三排。
你知道三排跟二排的差别在哪吗？
三排玩手机
其实比二排私密性更好。
有人讲说玩手机我要什么私密性。
我无所谓
真的无所谓吗？
你老公坐在二排刷了美女视频。
三排坐着你老婆的闺蜜。
看到了之后
回头下车跟你老婆讲说。
你看你老公刚在车上一直在刷美女视频。
对不对
你万一发消息
你一不小心
对吧？
你发那个亲爱的
你亲爱的坐在前面的。
你为什么手机上要发亲爱的。
是不是
那三排一看
你老妈看了
或者他
对不对
你的丈母粮看到了。
下车就跟你的媳妇要说了。
你小心点
他刚刚在二排你发消息。
亲爱的
所以三排有隐私性。
三排的后面不可能有人了吧？
对不对
三排后面要有人
那就不正常了
所以说三排后面都是放行李。
那行李如果放的太顶。
你的座椅的靠背就不一定能放倒。
但如果放的少一点。
你靠背还能放倒
还可以躺
你二排座椅
你就算有零重力
你开高速的时候你也不能挑。
所以你二排的座椅你要照顾三排。
可是三排的靠背你不用照顾前排的人。
是不是
三排有三排的好
而且三排的大肠腿。
你可以往前伸
中间不是有个过道。
对不对
所以为什么我在飞机上。
我就喜欢选靠过道。
就是当空姐不往前走的时候。
中间它明显那一段爬升。
或者是怎样
那我就可以把我的大肠腿稍微往往。
帮我过道去放一放。
对不对
那空姐开始发放食物的时候。
我就把它收回来
大体上就这样
所以我觉得三排有三排的好。
二排有二排的好
但是大体上
我还是蛮喜欢做三排。
我觉得三排挺有意思的。
然后后臂箱的容积我觉得还可以。
三排就算全部立起来。
放几个行李箱是没有任何问题的。
然后有40身的一个下沉的一个储物空间。
然后三排的后臂箱也是带电动放导。
一体式的两边一起放。
或者是一个一个放。
或者是电动调节
这些都是OK的
然后220V的插口。
还有12V的电源也全都是有的。
这个车现在还加了一个功能。
什么功能就是车外语音。
车外语音功能是降到。
录制声门
然后在车外
你可以让它打开全部车门。
左前车门右前车门。
打开后臂箱
这些都是全部都可以提前在车外去进行升控的。
然后我试了一下
我就挺好的
但是有一点就是
当你说打开车门的时候。
因为它是智能感应车门。
不是它一家
很多家都是这样
就是打开车门
你就不要再往车门前面走了。
因为它这个车门打开的过程当中。
一旦要是发现有人靠近。
它只开那么一小块。
就是一小颗口子
它实际上打开的角度是非常大的。
它这个角度你可以调吗？
但是你要如果说你它比较远。
你说打开车门
它开始完完全全打开。
你在走近它
这个是最方便的
上车踩脚刹车
主驾的车门自动关上。
这个是最合理的
所以我看到网上有人吐槽说。
车门不好用
我每次开的时候只能开一点。
而且每次开的角度都不一样。
为什么不一样
是因为它在开的过程中。
你站在侧面感应比较灵敏。
好吧？
那么最后讲一讲关于驾驶这一块。
这也是我想重点讲的。
其实官方讲说它的1.5T的增程系。
现在是第三代了
新一代的
什么热效率更高
油耗更低
WRTT的油耗从7.6降到6.3。
噪音 震动 控制都很不错。
这些东西我觉得
除非你是原先老的。
而且是很老的理想的车主。
比方说之前你是开理想万的。
东安的增程系
你现在再去开他们家现在自言增程。
你就知道说
这个增程系到底好在哪了。
但是问题在于
很多人买理想L9。
他可能之前没有开过老款的理想。
甚至于他都没有开过增程车。
那你跟他讲
这个油耗低
震动也降低了
噪音也降低了
他没有感知
你包括我现在试了那么多的车子。
有的是增程有的是插混。
其实在我看来
你要不跟我讲这个车是增程还是插混。
我开都正常开
我不会在意这些东西的。
除非它非常明显的。
噪音很大震动很大。
带速的过程当中开增程器。
我方向盘都在等
那我肯定要吐槽
但是绝大部分现在这种级别的车型。
不可能出现这种情况。
然后这个车现在是四颗激光力达。
那么它是一颗是
就是前向的激光力达在车顶上。
这个是远距离探测。
大家都知道最远是300米。
那么老款其实就这一颗激光力达。
现在是四颗
除了这一颗还有三颗在哪。
左前一字板
右前一字板
前一字板上面都会有叫做固态的。
可变胶的激光力达。
那么这个激光力达。
它其实是补盲区的。
左右侧的前一字板是补这个横向来车。
包括一些加塞
还有飞机动车
它的反应速度会更快。
探测的会更加的密集。
那么车尾部
还有一颗
叫做也是固态的可变胶。
那么这个激光力达是用来补后方盲区。
相当于包括你高速的时候。
你要变到
你虽然通过后视镜在看。
你觉得没有车
但是也许这个车好巧不巧。
就在你的盲区里面。
对吧？
那它就可以提前预知。
就不让你变到
它会有报警
包括像倒车AEB。
我们知道有些人停车。
它不是车屁股进去。
它是车头一头砸进去。
或者说
你像有一些商场的停车场小区的地库。
你停在正好是卷连门的旁边。
或者是某一堵墙的旁边。
这个停车位是最差的。
为什么呢？
因为你当你出来的时候。
你的左前方就是盲区。
或者你的右前方就是盲区。
所以一定要上车之前先看一看。
左右两侧有没有人。
有没有车
那我一般都不停这个位置。
我但凡有其他的车位。
我一定是要停到一个能够视线。
左右看的非常开阔的这样一个停车位。
哪怕就是可能位置比较小。
我也是停这个位置。
因为毕竟
你就小磕小碰无所谓。
开门杀
我对开门杀一点意见都没有。
我的车刚买来
一个星期不到就被人开门杀了。
我当时就黑黑一笑。
对吧？
早被撞往被撞
早晚都得被撞
是不是
这就淡定一点
但是像这种停车规避风险。
我觉得
还是不要立于危墙之下。
但是现在有了AEB。
就会相对好一点
它会通过后方的雷达。
你如果你是
到车出来的时候
你看不到左右两方。
它其实会帮你提前探测。
那么航运内
目前来讲
我觉得航运内一颗激光雷达算是标配。
两颗激光雷达算是高配。
三颗激光雷达相当于就是顶配。
旗舰车了
四颗是什么概念
四颗就是不计成本。
你可以用什么AI。
什么GPT
兜包
你去搜一搜
目前市面上有多少车型。
用四颗激光雷达的。
而且基本都是这样的一个配置。
一颗是前置激光雷达。
然后三颗激光雷达就是左前右前。
然后后方基本都是这样。
那么接下来就是重点。
我想讲的就是
这一次让我印象最深最深的。
就是它的这个800V的主动旋挂。
那么节目一开始我也讲了。
我在网上本来想说一说。
我对主动旋挂为什么印象那么深。
结果很多网友讲说。
你好好去学一学
了解完之后你再过来讲。
那么好
今天我一天我就在研究这个。
我把我研究的成果。
我把我查了一些资料。
给大家来进行分享。
那么如果说有说的不到位的。
或者说是有一路的地方。
我希望大家评论区可以一起来探讨。
可以来进行补充
那么首先就是现在主流的。
或者说现在目前能看到旗舰车型上配的。
800V的全主动旋挂。
我刚刚提到一个就是问界的M9。
M9之前只有在Ultimate这个版本上有。
但是马上要上的全新一代的M9。
那么大概率可能就是M9的叫领式加厂版Ultimate。
再加上普通的版本。
就是标准版本的有可能它都有。
因为我已经拿到他们家的官方的一个。
关于配置的一个表。
这个表里面显示的就是说。
在底盘架构这一块。
两边基本都一致
都是叫做新一代的华为图灵全主动底盘平台。
新一代的智能预描架控融合架构。
全新双子座双戎鱼架构。
双罚CDC再加上双枪臂式空穴。
这个一栏是Ultimate跟标准的M9。
都是在同一个框框里面。
那么大概率他们应该是统一了。
那么差别是什么呢？
就是全新一代M9的Ultimate的版本。
是线控转向加后轮转向。
但是普通版本是后轮转向。
这一块我当时看到。
关于底盘架构是有一点区别的。
那么800V的全主动旋架。
理想L9，Levis跟M9这一块。
用的它的主要的原理其实都是一样的。
它其实都是一套
包括像空穴CDC。
包括独立EF4个车轮。
4个的旁边都会有。
然后加上高压管路。
底盘控制逻辑
然后包括他们自己会去统筹去调教。
那么各家调教的风格。
肯定也是不一样的。
那么这里面基本上是以咱们国内的。
国产的供应链为主。
这也是网上很多人讨论。
就是说这个技术是不是咱们自己的。
有没有核心字眼
有没有去到国外采购。
会不会被将来的海外的供应商制约。
我查不到它是不是100%全部字眼。
100%全部是国产的零部件。
查不到
也可能会混用一些海外的供应商。
但是根据之前空旋的这个。
咱们国内厂商吃过的亏。
吃过的亏就是国外卡我们的销量。
包括这些东西
你想包括主动旋挂。
包括先空转向
包括后轮转向
这都是为了将来的L3 L4做准备的。
那今后全部都是用电。
把这些机械的转向柱。
这些东西全部都要去掉了。
对不对
那些什么限数
全部的大范围的全部要减少掉。
全部都得用限控
用后轮
用全主动旋挂
都是按照这个逻辑走的将来的L3 L4。
所以我相信
任何一家车席
甚至在网上相关的主管部门。
它也是不能接受
你到今天为止还在用海外的供应商。
核心的技术还是海外的。
是不行的
但是我没查到
是不是100%全国产。
如果有相关的这个行业内的人。
能不能跟我们讲一讲。
也可能会有一些混用海外的一些相关的零部件。
但是主导一定是咱们国内主导的。
那么这个800V的全主动旋轿。
它是直接用整车的800V的高压电池供电。
这个跟48V是有比较大的区别。
48V是降压
因为这个理想讲的是自己是900V平台。
所以它900V的话是降压。
然后48V去供电。
所以说它800V是直接供。
直接供
然后液压棒动力单元是装在车身上。
然后它是靠高压油管去连接四轮的减震器。
它执行机构不装在车轮上的。
所以它不增加皇下质量。
那么皇下质量在我之前的节目里面。
也曾经提到过
这里稍微解释一下。
就是在一些改装车或者是性能车的圈子里面。
就流传着这句话叫做。
皇下减重一公斤
皇上减重十公斤
或者叫做轮上一公斤。
车上十马力
你都可以这么讲
什么意思呢？
就是你皇下轮就是塘环。
下方皇下质量
你要能减重一公斤。
一般情况下去
然后说换轮骨换轮圈。
对不对
轮圈换轻量化
那么你的皇上
其实这个坦皇的皇。
皇上面
它这个不是实际减重。
它是车身的这种减重的效果。
性能的效果
相当于是减了十公斤。
或者我们讲的再抽象一点。
就有点像
你原来是穿穿了一双这种。
马丁靴啊？
或者是高桶的小皮靴啊？
那很帅
但是走起路来肯定是不舒服的。
现在给你换了一双跑鞋。
你说你的人的重量有变化吗？
没有
但是你穿了一双跑鞋。
你就感觉你跑起来特别的轻快。
你要到这个逻辑走其实就能理解了。
所以它不增加皇下质量。
这一点我觉得还是比较关键的。
那么？
整体来讲
它的单轮的推动力。
单轮的推力能超过一万扭。
能超过一万扭
也就是一吨几
那这个是什么意思呢？
最近是两天啊？
因为之前理想区演示它。
L9李维斯的单侧车轮能够翘起来。
然后能够直接换轮胎。
翘起来之后下面放一个马凳。
马凳先顶一下子
然后车辆识别到之后。
它轮胎就直接往上收起。
收完之后
你可以悬空了
悬空之后把它给换下来。
然后再把马凳撤掉。
轮胎换好之后
它会自动再加下来。
那么演示完之后呢？
现在各大车企也开始用这个方式去演示。
换轮胎的三条腿走路的。
我的妈呀？
以后我说句实在话。
你的车要是不会三条腿走路。
你要是不会这个什么蹦蹦跳跳。
摇一摇啊？
爷爷的爷爷
不对爷爷的爷爷叫什么？
我也不知道
应该是爸爸的爸爸叫什么？
对吧？
你要是不会这个
我觉得你都不好意思跟人打招呼。
但是呢？
这种我也能理解
它毕竟是营销宣传。
大家对于什么叫做全主动全卦。
可能并不是很了解。
只能通过这种最直观的方式。
通过短视频平台通过网络。
让大家知道
我的车有这个功能。
别人没有
对吧？
其实这是个好东西。
真的是个好东西
其实它这个好
不在于说
它能够像小狗尿尿一样。
抬起一只腿
就前提一定是只母狗。
公狗啊？
因为母狗不是这么尿的。
母狗
怎么就叫它母狗
公狗尿尿去了
公狗尿尿你肯定知道的。
抬起一只腿
它那种方式
我觉得真的就像一只小公狗。
在尿尿一样的
那么它通过这种方式。
其实让你知道它有这么一个功能。
它是可以通过它的单轮的推力。
让这个车辆形成一些。
我们之前从来没有想过。
从来没有见过的姿态。
它是靠大的这种力量。
去主动抬升
或者是下压它的车身。
甚至于包括
现在的功能是可以实现。
但是有些车它程序没写进去。
甚至可以包括什么？
我讲个很夸张的
你靠近车辆
一般车子不就是解锁亮灯吗？
我告诉你
有这个功能之后
它可以给你点头
欢迎三刀
您回家啦
欢迎老板
祝你一路顺风一路平安。
因为你车外有语音。
完全ok啊？
它车子可以给你点头。
甚至可以给你扎眼睛。
对不对
我们讲前大灯都可以看电影了。
你这扎个眼睛有什么问题的呢？
它可以给你扎扎眼睛。
它可以给你点点头。
点头不就是靠800V的。
将你一个全主动全挖。
行神的吗？
对不对
你让它给你跳一下都没什么问题。
每次乘车之前给你跳一下。
哇 三刀你来了
我好兴奋啊？
对不对
如果我一个月没开车。
突然有一天去开车。
哇 三刀
你来宠信我了
让它很开心啊？
它跳一下
这不很正常吗？
对不对
这都是800V高压。
给你提供情绪价值。
这不挺好吗？
是不是
还有什么呢？
包括你比方说在露营的时候。
你露营的时候
你肯定是看到哪边风景好。
我哪边停吗？
旁边有小溪水
后面是不要靠山
后面是靠树
很阴凉
你靠山很危险
露营一般都是靠水。
然后靠小树
那么你车体在旁边呢？
你发现这个
它不平
它不平有什么问题呢？
你包括你想从车上去搭一个小桌椅出来。
或者说是你想
就是你那种
叫做车边椅 车边杖。
对吧？
从车上拉出一个小帐篷。
车边杖 车边椅
或者是你想用它的后背箱。
你发现的后背箱是歪的。
我告诉你
从此以后
像这种车型
你去露营
它不会歪
它可以停在任何一个。
这种路面非常不平准的地方。
那你不要说停在什么悬崖撬壁。
那个太夸张了嘛？
就是你露只要稍微不平。
它可以给你调平
为什么呀？
因为它是800V全主动旋挂。
四个轮可以独立调节。
前后左右给你调平。
我的妈 你敢想吗？
你不敢想
包括你要如果说将来车子要是掀到沙子里面了。
它可以抬起一个车轮。
然后你把那个
这个拖困板给它插进去嘛？
对不对
要不然的话你怎么抬。
你三吨的车你根本抬不动。
两吨多你也抬不动。
你可以把它直接车轮撬起来。
往里面一抬
甚至于它可以自己蹦蹦跳跳。
它不一定能跳出来。
它蹦蹦跳跳
这样的话它可以想办法来前前后后。
前前后后蹦蹦跳跳。
它不就脱困了吗？
所以要什么硬派乐业。
搞个电动车哪都去得了。
哪都去得了
是不是
所以像这种800V的全主动旋挂。
它可以压制点头的情况。
侧紧的情况
可以去主动去预描这种大的坑挖。
主动去
它不是被动去在坑里面就光光光。
去通过旋轮全挂去绿震。
它可以去主动伸缩。
然后去避免这种大坑挖的。
车辆这种跳跃或者说是车内的抚养侧倾。
然后甚至于它可以直接取消机械的防情感。
但是这种取消与不取消。
主要是看厂家对于产品的定义了。
它的极限值到底要多高。
在什么环境下用
产品到底是怎么定义的。
不一定都取消
那么未来的48V的主动情况。
它是集成式的
我们刚刚前面讲的800V是分体式的。
这个是属于集成式的。
2022年的时候。
其实未来就跟一家叫做ClearMotion的公司。
就开始合作
那我的微博当时也是把ClearMotion的工程师的访谈节目。
是搬过来放到我的微博上。
感兴趣你可以去看一看。
它们相当于就是
不是你叫做叫做叫什么？
罚名家或者叫做
它们相当于就是这个东西的源头。
你可以这么理解
源头的工程师跟你去讲解。
这个是很值得一看的。
等于就是在
这个未来的相当于是900V的架构基础上。
900V降压
然后降压到48V低压开始进行供电。
它每个车轮的减震器是直接集成电机。
加上液压棒
然后是钻在轮端
所以它会增加皇下质量。
因为它这个车本身。
它就没有说要走什么操控运动的路线。
增加就增加了
它不是性能车
我们讲说什么？
皇下一公斤
皇上十公斤
不是按照这个逻辑走的。
它要的是稳
它要的是旗舰级那种开出去的扎实的路感。
所以它这种车型按照这个逻辑走。
它没有长的管路
它的指令它没有延迟。
因为它距离最近
它没有延迟
然后单轮的推力大概是在3000N。
所以你会发现
它跟800V全主动全挂。
它的单轮推力就完全不一样了。
它是3000N
推力虽然小
但是调节速度极快。
所以它讲究的是快。
前面的800V讲究的是大力出奇迹。
所以它们的调节逻辑。
跟体感上都是有区别的。
800V的全主动全降。
是我刚刚讲大力出奇迹。
对吧？
包括它擅长是大行程。
就是大的坑挖
然后大幅度的控制。
山路上面反复的这种左右的摇摆。
对吧？
然后急速的加速
就加急加速急减速。
这种刹车点头
然后包括像我前面讲的。
就是路营
车身的调节去调平。
是这些
它是有优势的
但是它的管路稍微会有一些延迟。
然后它对路面的细微的颠簸。
以及这种高频的小震动。
它过滤的细腻程度。
肯定是不如未来的48V。
那么未来48V的优势就是。
它的高频精细的V条非常强。
每秒上千次的调节。
然后是好秒级的
而且它可以去在那种。
就是频繁的碎石路面上。
从碎石路面上
它可以把细微的颠簸。
连续的细碎的震动。
可以就是过滤的非常好。
其实都不叫过滤了。
我觉得这个就直接调节掉了。
就完全就把它调节掉了。
所以底盘它的贴地感。
它的整体的这种细腻程度。
就像我们讲说开这个车。
感觉底盘很整
我觉得不能用整了。
就你已经感觉不出来。
这个底盘在工作
你都感觉不出来
它在工作
悬挂抛跳什么的
我还知道这个悬挂在帮我去避震。
这些减震器在帮我避震。
但是现在你就完全无感了。
都已经是
几乎是无感
所以它的细腻程度。
包括它整体车内的。
这种高级的驾驶感受。
静秘的感受是会更加的强。
但是它的推力有限。
对于应付一些大的坑挖。
大的冲击
大的侧倾
所以它的压制力
会稍微弱于800伏的这样一个方案。
那么简单来讲
没有48伏的主动学家好与不好。
或者是800伏的全主动学家好与不好。
这个说法
网上的争论我觉得毫无意义。
各有各的好处
各有各的适用范围。
800伏跟适用于。
大部分的这种家用。
舒适多路况
高速稳定性特别烂的一些路。
跟适合
然后48伏的未来的这样的一个全主动学家。
它主打的就是城市的那种豪华感。
行政的一种感觉
高级平顺
那么限控转向这个简单待遇就可以了。
限控转向我是觉得一般人感知也不大。
但是我当时在驾驶过程当中。
因为我一出门我把它调动运动模式。
那么在运动模式下。
它的整体原地打方向的这种转向力举。
你会感觉还是比较重的。
手感是比较重的
但是你要如果调到舒适模式。
立马就不一样了
就变得很轻松
它这种限控转向就跟我们玩模礼系一样。
是完全可以根据你的个性化自定义。
或者说它按照舒适运动。
包括什么塞道各种模式可以进行调解。
而且相关的数据在屏幕里面。
其实都能看得见
真的就跟打游戏一样。
就真的什么都能看得见。
你可以根据它来精细的去进行调解。
就调出一个你最喜欢的这种转向手感。
都是OK的
然后后轮转向就不用怎么说了。
因为这车已经超过5米2了。
但是转完半径5米4还是比较小的。
因为这种转完半径对于这种体量的大车来讲。
在路口能够一把吊头吊过来就已经非常不错了。
这两点我觉得可以有。
但是你没有我也正常开。
有当然更好
对吧？
但是试驾过程当中。
我觉得是冲着这个去买的应该是比较少的。
感知度不是特别的高。
而且我相信有些人试车可能也不会去试这些功能。
那么简单总结一下吧？
其实我觉得就这一代的理想的L9。
我们因为试的只是Levis这个版本。
我觉得Levis这个版本从里到外都深了一遍。
然后这个价格在原先的L9的40来万的基础上。
又上了个10万块钱。
这10万值不值呢？
我觉得这10万是这样的。
在原先定义40来万去买L9的人严厉。
它是不值的
我觉得你让它多少10万块钱可能性不大。
这些功能其实说白了。
能改善
但是没有我照样能开。
对吧？
所以他们要的这些冰箱产业大沙发。
我相信L9上面也都是有的。
所以Levis对它的吸引力不一定那么大。
但是还是那句话
如果一旦这个人之前看的是M9 Ultimate。
他看的是ES9的。
带天行底盘
然后带48V的全主动旋卦的。
那这一部分的人的预算。
6710他去买这个55万预售。
可能真正上市价格更低。
他买了L9没毛病。
我觉得一点问题没有。
而且你想看未来是纯电车。
只不过它是换点
那么M9它是真诚。
但是真诚跟真诚之间。
包括支架和支架之间。
车机跟车机之间
还是有席位的差别。
包括在配置上
甚至包括在这种车内的定义的这种体感上来讲。
还是有差别
你坐上M9你的感觉像什么？
感觉就像是
我好像我要去开会。
对吧？
二排的座椅边上
地板上可能放的是这个公文包。
但是你看到L9的车上。
你感觉这个车子不下去开会。
像是回家
带娃去亲子去出行。
旁边放的是老婆的手林包。
放的是孩子的书包。
M9就像是放的老板的手林包。
就这么一些差别
你说都到了这种级别上。
你还能有什么配置差。
还能有什么具体的体感上的。
绝对的这种降维打击的差异。
不可能
绝对不可能
所以车它不是越贵。
越适合家用
技术也不是越多
越懂家庭
我觉得好的旗舰车型。
它不是营销出来的。
是开了几年之后
如果你觉得这车
这个钱花的它不是很约。
那是可以的
而且你一定要去问一问老车主。
它对你的隐藉
就这车道用的好不好。
它开了几年之后什么感受。
有没有什么明显的缺点。
有没有什么我不能接受的一些。
这种没满足的需求点。
对吧？
那这些你去问问老车主。
这个比你在网上看什么100个铁盒。
100条视频要强的多的多。
那今天就聊那么多。
我觉得理想的L9 Levis。
因为这个车的功能点特别多。
然后我体验的也比较的详细。
所以有很多话想讲。
但是我不管怎么讲。
我不占任何的队
节目最后我还是要给自己叠个BUFF。
听到最后都是老铁。
我不占任何的队
我觉得现在旗舰级的这种SUV也好。
较车也好
做的都很不错
而且咱们国产性能源。
现在整合供应链的这种能力。
是雾用质疑的
你不用去说觉得好像这些功能。
是不是新功能上车之后。
有一些没有保障
咱们国内的制造能力还是非常强的。
而且你想这个车
也不是一年给它上了个新款。
它四年打磨到今天才上。
销量到最后都是垮成那个样子了。
理想也不着急
到了今天上一个理想的L9全新换单。
它心里面其实是有数的。
作为旗舰车型
它只能成功不能失败。
它绝对是不能忍受这个车。
一上市就出现什么负面新闻的。
所以也不能讲说上市。
我就建议大家买
但是我觉得这车是值得关注的。
只不过很遗憾
就到目前为止
我肯定是买不了5米3这种级别的车。
停车是个问题
等到将来小孩上大学了。
对吧？
我跟老爸两个人我们搬出去。
找个地方去养老去住的时候。
停车方便了
那个时候解禁了
就可以去买一个咱们自己真正喜欢的。
然后宽畅的
带着老爸出去自驾游的车了。
那么现在来讲的话。
考虑的更多的还是。
我觉得像支架
支仓
这些使用性的问题。
而且用不了多久
800V全主动全挂。
包括理想这种48V。
我估计陆陆续续往下都会去普及。
而且会越来越便宜。
那么那个时候我再换。
这个配置是我一定要的。
是我肯定100%是要的一个功能配置。
而且都有了这些配置了。
我相信支架支仓也不会差。
好吧？
好
以上就是关于今天节目的主要内容。
那么大家如果感兴趣的话。
评论区也可以留言互动一起交流。
评论我都会看
那么每期节目的留言区。
我们会抽三位
在下一期进行一个互动。
那么这三位每个人可以获得由。
人研计提供的预露相离一个试试装。
每一盒里面有5颗。
非常的好吃
大家如果想购买
也可以搜索小程序。
摆车全说
那么在我们的线上商城里面进行下单购买。
那么刚刚可能有人听到一个细节。
说三刀
你这个是换赞助商了吗？
我记得是叫任研计。
你这赞助商换成人研计了。
这是两个牌子名字这么像吗？
这个我们讲到今天第一条留言。
很有意思
这位网友的名字叫做。
W-H-O-S-O-S-E-R-I-O-U-S-K-T。
W-H-O-S-O-S-O-S-E-R-I-O-U-S-K-T。
就这哥们
他起了个养稳
他说
刀哥
我给你打5块钱都赌。
任研计这个认
他不读第四声
他应该读第二声
读人
他说你不信你可以去问问那个创始人。
那么结果呢？
我就去问了一下
结果一问
我就发现我还真读错了。
创始人也跟我讲说应该是读人。
那我觉得就有意思了。
我读了这么久任研计。
这哥们竟然一句话都不说。
他明显要么就是没听我节目。
要么就是
要么就是什么？
就是觉得也无所谓了。
反正你能
只要能说出这个名字。
对吧？
大家经常能搜索得到。
都是可以的
但是我觉得还是对他表示抱歉。
就赞助了我们这么久的节目。
到现在还在赞助
结果的名字第一个字。
我读第几声一直都读错。
因为他确实是个多音字。
但是这个
因为他在这个叫姓氏里面一般都是读人。
但是如果是要是担任什么任务。
责任
常用词的话
一般都是读人
所以说如果用于姓氏。
用于地名
明显任研计
他更偏向于是一个比较说姓任的哥们。
创始的
所以就任研计
或者说叫什么什么计。
他就跟人家偏向于一个品牌。
一个IP
所以他就读第二声叫人研计。
好
从今天开始我们就读人研计。
那么也是感谢
就这么久了
既然有这第一次
有一位听友提出这个读的不对。
而且他提的还是正确的。
那必须要送你一箱。
郁鲁香梨
好吧？
连续盾牌
盾牌的微信
46415254。
然后赶紧
收到郁鲁香梨好好的啃一啃。
一边吃一边想
这三刀
你看我给你揪个醋。
吃个梨的感觉多好。
是吧？
好
我们下一位听友叫做。
Mr.DALIB。
这应该是怎么读
Mr.Dalibi。
这不是骂人的话
哎呀？
不管了
反正就是Mr.DALIB。
他说
刀哥
你的意思是
OTA升级在有关部门报备。
就等同于审查
我觉得这个说法不准确。
备案更多的是
OTA改动的相关参数。
给他做一个记录
功能调整内容
以及他的负责主体。
责任主体
核心的作用是
后续出现问题
能够精准的溯源
明确他的责任
并不是对底层代码进行实质性的审查。
那么各家车企
车企系统都是封闭。
非开源的
监管部门很难配备足够专业人员。
对于每款车型的OTA进行主航代码的排查。
就算人力能够实现。
面对海量的车企跟车型。
OTA审批周期
也会被无限拉长
而且即便完成审查。
也没有办法做到百分之百没有问题。
所以备案本质是合规的信息登记。
和实质性的技术审查完全是两回事。
你说指望单纯的靠报备来降低隐患。
这个并不现实
关键还是要靠完善的追责制度和法规。
让车企严格自我约束。
这哥们儿这语气语调。
我这一听就是像相关领导部门给我下发文件。
这滴水不漏
条理清晰
我的天
这哥们儿你是不是相关部门。
你是不是就是干这个的OTA网信部的。
怎么这么精正啊？
这段话写的太专业了。
Mr.DRIB
赠送你一箱欲露相离。
吃一吃
你回头要不联系下盾牌。
咱们联系联系
以后这方面的问题我再问问你。
这明显是个专业人士。
好我们下一位听有叫做穆穆穆。
MUMUMU
他说道哥
听说你要买苹果的手表是吧？
我是S5的用户
虽然有点老
但是我想告诉你
我用了很久
这个使用体验是怎样的。
这个AppleWash啊？
第一个就是续航太拉了。
真的是非常拉
而且有的时候还发烫。
然后你还会担心什么屏幕滑伤。
这些
所以旅游的时候
你出门的时候稍微小心一点。
而且每次出门
你要带个充电器就很麻烦。
那么用途是什么呢？
用途啊？
首先第一个
它那个三环特别有魔力。
就以前你没有养成这种习惯。
什么运动啊？
站立啊这些
但是有了这个三环之后。
它的确会让你养成运动的习惯。
这里给大家解释一下。
什么叫三环啊？
大家看过那个苹果的手表。
而且有一些什么华强北或者其他的一些品牌。
也是学习它
它有三种不同的颜色。
就三根环
红环呢？
叫做活动
绿环叫做锻炼
然后还有个蓝环叫做站立。
一听就明白了嘛？
那么活动呢？
就是本质上一天你消耗了多少热量。
就像于走路啊？
就是正常的爬楼啊？
跑步啊？
跑步还算啊？
跑步应该也算
就是正常的走
就是你人在正常的走动的情况下。
苹果会给你一个目标。
就比如说500大卡。
那你要是完成了这个大卡。
那就红环就闭合了嘛？
对吧？
你每天去让你去消耗卡路里嘛？
你不能光吃不动
那不就变胖
不健康啊？
那么绿环叫做锻炼。
就是你是针对性的有目的的。
那么这种它一般会有要求一定的心率。
还有就是动作达到它的快走以上的水平。
就是比你正常走路要快嘛？
还有包括像跑步骑车健身这些。
那都是在这个绿环里面。
进行这个就是相当于消耗嘛？
就绿环如果闭合了。
那么它默认是30分钟。
要求也不是特别的高。
那么你今天的这个绿环就完成了。
那么蓝环是战利
战利是什么意思呢？
就是很多人觉得很奇怪。
这战利为什么要测。
按照它的要求就是一天。
一个人在至少12个小时。
这个就是他默认
你其他12个小时。
可能是休息嘛？
就你这12个小时。
每一小时要站起来活动一分钟。
因为苹果认为酒做的伤害很大。
它会提醒你站起来。
这个功能我真的特别喜欢。
我原来买过一块这个智能手标。
也是会让它给我做提醒。
但是是闹钟提醒
还有就是我的电脑上也会长期安装一个软件。
我的软件其实很小。
只有好像几百KB吧？
但很好用
叫Snap Tamer SNAPTIMER。
这是个非常老的软件。
而且这个软件我来看一眼。
这个软件好像没有中文。
对没有中文
但是它其实很简单。
这些大家都能看得懂。
Star Reset。
这个什么Setting。
这些大家应该都知道。
就这几个按键
非常简单的一个计时功能。
但这个功能就是每一个小时。
它会自动跳出来一次。
时间你可以自己设。
我现在就点了一下。
它就开始倒计时了。
然后你把它最小化。
最小化就在右边的任务栏里面。
所以我就会用这个叫Snap Tamer。
在我的Windows的电脑上。
但是苹果上也有很多的小软件。
做提醒也非常好
我建议大家就是你如果长期复安工作。
就设置一下
我就会
想得起来我就会用它。
就一个小时左右起来。
也喝个水
走一走转一转
主要就是腰椎
腰椎包括脊椎这一块。
你要经常放松
你要经常不放松的话。
很容易就是击牢陈脊。
我前两天看
是那个
就是极度发达是小桥。
我看他前两天好像是住院了。
听说好像就是这个。
腰椎肩盘突出还是什么？
那天我看到评论区有人讲。
我没仔细看
咱们汽车圈里面
我知道了这种紧椎不好的。
腰椎肩盘突出的人很多。
很多
所以我觉得就是你平时注意不注意的问题。
你包括你的比方说人体工学椅。
像我家里办公室的座椅。
全都是带这种人体工学靠垫的。
然后我现在办公室的椅子换掉了。
前段时间还有人问我说。
你的人体工学椅
最后订了哪个牌子买了吗？
什么型号
我跟大家来同步一下。
我买了
我一次性买了差不多9张椅子。
然后我自己一张
然后我们同事几张。
老板的预算就会稍微高一点。
我买的是泳衣的550T。
相当于他们家旗舰了。
然后也不算最旗舰。
基本上算是旗舰
次旗舰了
然后咱们同事们买的都是。
我给同事们买的都是这个叫。
WalkPro
因为我们公司有几把椅子。
本身质量还挺好的。
所以我就给他们又配了几把。
我们公司一共十来个人。
所以他们是用WalkPro。
也是泳衣的
我是泳衣的550T。
那基本就是我们去订了这个牌子。
这个型号
也不如说给他打广告。
但是我想讲
感谢我们朗老师
因为当时我在买这个人体工学椅的时候。
我在网上看了很多。
像稀号
包括像泳衣
后来我也搜了一下海外的这种品牌。
我也去试点
我去试了一下
但是我发现
其实这个椅子刚开始看。
你就开始陷入到对于各种功能的追求。
但是实际上真正你想想看。
这个椅子它本质上没有什么功能需求。
什么放倒 躺椅
就没有这些
你只要用的顺手就可以了。
然后后来我去多方位试了一下。
多方面试了一下之后。
我就发现
第一个我一定是要网布的。
因为我看到最近那个倾斜也很火。
但是倾斜
它那个座椅下方
它是棉布
不是网布
虽然它也讲什么带通风 透气。
但我不需要
我觉得网布就够了。
所以我是一定要有网布的。
然后功能调节肯定是。
角度各方面也能调到最舒适的是最合理的。
对吧？
那无非就是各家
它就是功能调节的多和少的问题。
然后相关的材质
对吧？
用的什么气感
下面的托盘就底盘。
轮子这些地方是金属的。
或者是工程塑料
它就有些区别
所以我就很清楚了。
这东西没有什么高的基础含量。
无非就是各家的设计。
做工用料的一些水准。
那我想找找人
因为我当时看了一下。
正好是在安吉
勇易是在安吉生产的。
我想想那安吉生产的。
那我安吉咱有人
老老师也上过我的节目。
后来我一问老老师。
老老师说
勇易的老板跟他妈是朋友。
说这个地方就这么大。
对吧？
做生意的基本都认识。
这由此可见
老老师家的生意做得有多大。
结果他们直接给安排了。
勇易的销售总监
就全国的销售老大给我发了个消息。
加了个微信
加完之后老大就直接安排了一个。
负责区域销售的
就跟了一下我这个单子。
然后最后给的价格确实是。
就是你哪怕双十一天拿不到这个价。
后来他很珍贵非常珍贵。
下单的时候也是给了我一份合同。
然后下面也是有一份配货单。
然后配货单上面写的也很清楚。
右侧写的非常清晰。
就是什么什么老总特批。
什么什么老总特批。
就这个单子
所以最后我们拿的价格还是。
我觉得至少省了应该有2000多块钱。
具体我花了多少钱就不透露了。
因为他毕竟是特批价。
但是我就算了一下。
哪怕就是在因为马上618了。
我看他的这个平台还是保价。
我即使在他618保价的情况下。
在线上买和我在线上线下。
我就找了这个领导之后。
找了熟人关系
省了也差不多2000来块钱。
所以这个老老师也听到了是吧？
所以这2000来块钱。
其实我觉得这省了。
省了也是将来要把它请出去的。
所以老老师下次来南京。
咱们去吃龙虾啊？
去吃龙虾
这龙虾咱们几个人一吃。
也是千把块钱肯定是跑不掉的。
嘿嘿嘿
所以省的钱在人情上面。
给他还回去了
对吧？
我自己上网买
咱也不用还人情
但是现在讲起来呢？
咱椅子也到家了
对吧？
龙虾将来也能吃到肚子里面。
那么挺好的吧？
所以关系我觉得还是要多动一动。
多用一用
有些人我觉得大部分人会觉得说。
就买个椅子吗？
三刀你也不差这几个钱。
你先上下单就是了。
本身也不贵
但是我总是会想到。
哎
我一看到当时安吉。
因为我会用各种这种。
什么豆包啊？
全是GPT会去查。
你知道吗？
然后查查查
有一天就是突然查到。
这个比较多稀号是哪边产的。
然后泳衣是哪边产的。
我就发现安吉
我第一反应就是找到蓝老师。
随口就问了一下
我当时就给他发了一条信息了。
结果一问正巧
就认识他们老板
所以大底长就是这么个情况。
跟大家来回报一下。
身边事
聊的也挺有意思的。
那行
以上就是本期节目。
所有的内容给大家收听。
如果觉得节目不错。
可以帮我点点赞
评论评论和转发
没有订阅的朋友
小宇宙和喜马拉雅。
都可以点击一下订阅。
订阅完之后
每周三每周六更新都会有提醒。
那么？
如果你是在用
喜马拉雅收听节目的话。
在喜马拉雅手机端的播放页面。
就是小三角的下方有月票。
免费的月票也可以帮我投一投。
那么对于我节目曝光。
会很有帮助
那么我更多的原创内容。
包括像Bilibili。
账号叫摆车全说
每周五更新一起尝视频。
还有就是像抖音
快手视频号小红书。
这些都是短视频平台。
搜索
三刀
砍车
单人旁
砍大山的砍
那么以及我的个人微博。
摆车全说三刀
还有就是我的公众号。
摆车全说
想要联系我们
或者跟我一对一交流。
也可以加入微信
4641 5254。
好
我们今天这期节目就到这。
下期节目
接着聊
拜拜